It makes it look like we're on a radio
show.
Yeah.
The Joe Rogan experience
Joe Rogan podcast by night.
Yes.
Ladies and gentlemen,
welcome back.
Randall Carlson.
How are you,
sir?
I'm doing well.
Joe,
you freaked out the entire podcast
population the last time you were here
with your stories of cataclysmic
disasters and,
and,
uh,
the,
ramifications of asteroidal impacts and
just the,
the evidence that you presented was a
real mindfuck as it were.
Well,
uh,
what can I say?
I apologize to all the listeners out
there that might have had nightmares.
No worries.
I knew that was going to be the case
though.
I knew after the first time I met you,
we had that long conversation in
Atlanta.
I knew once you sat down for three hours
on a podcast and open up about that
stuff,
it was really going to uncork a lot of
people's domes.
Well,
you know,
ironically there's an upside to the
whole thing.
Maybe we'll have time to get into that a
little bit today.
Yeah,
definitely.
So tell me,
you just returned from a long excursion
with Graham Hancock if you want to bend
that thing like that towards your face
or probably work a little.
Yeah,
there you go.
You just returned from a long excursion
with Graham Hancock.
You guys were on the road.
And what was the nature of your trip?
Where we were.
I was taking Graham on a tour showing
them some landscapes.
Um,
we were,
I could haul them to the landscapes of
catastrophe because he's doing his
secret two fingerprints of the gods.
And you know,
when he came out with that book in 1995,
he was theorizing that there had been
this lost civilization in prehistoric
times and you know,
the critics,
the gist of most of what the critics
were attacking him on and there were
considerable attacks on him as a result
of some of the things he put forward in
that book was that,
well,
if there was this great civilization
that had existed in,
you know,
somewhere back in prehistory.
Where's the evidence of it?
Where,
where is the worst of pottery?
You know,
where are the carvings were,
where is the infrastructure that would
have existed and you know,
I don't know if he really had an answer
for that other than the fact that there
had been a cataclysmic events that had
intervened between then and now,
but he wasn't really specific about what
the nature of those catastrophes
actually,
we're in a lot of additional research
has come out since 1995.
That basically opens the window onto
those events that basically separates
our modern history,
which,
you know,
the recorded history goes back five or
6,000
years.
You,
when we look at
the emergence of modern civilization,
we would basically trace it back to nine
or 10,000
years ago with the emergence of,
of um,
uh,
you know,
agriculture,
a dispersion of languages,
the first cities and so forth.
When we go beyond that a few thousand
years,
we're in a completely different world
and I mean,
so completely different that it's almost
unrecognizable from our modern world.
If we started recreating maps,
a going backwards,
like taking snapshots of the planet
every millennium,
going back,
what we would see is that going back to
seven or 8,000
years ago with the basic configuration
of our planet would not change much.
Once we get 11,
12,
13,000
years ago,
the change has become profoundly
dramatic.
We start seeing sea levels going down
hundreds of feet.
We see massive ice sheets covering North
America and Europe and and lots of other
enormous changes.
Beyond that is what I considered to be
deep history because as we may have
talked about in our last interview,
you know,
we modern humans have been on this
planet for a 150 to 200,000
years.
At least.
You know,
if we go back,
say I think the oldest modern human
skeleton ever found was named Homo adult
too,
and he dates to about 180,000
years roughly if we think of a
generation of humans is 25 years.
That's 7,000
generations of humans now.
So the question is,
what were we doing for all those
thousands of generations until somebody
finally realized,
Hey,
you know what,
we can plant crops,
we can,
you know,
we can build cities,
we can form communities,
you know,
we can invent language,
etc.
Etc.
WEll,
my contention is,
and I think the evidence that's
accumulating supports this
interpretation at what we're really
seeing seven,
eight,
9,000
years ago,
is not the origins of civilization,
but the rebooting of civilization.
You see what I'm saying?
And when we go back and we realize that
modern history is separated from deep
history by this extraordinary series of
events that transpired between about 11
and 13 or 14,000
years ago.
Once We begin to recognize how extreme
these these events were in remodeling
our planet,
totally remodeling our planet,
it then becomes obvious to us why there
is not a lot of hard evidence for
whatever went on prior to these,
to these events.
And there's been some things that they
found since then that have really sort
of made graham hancock's theories become
more and more palatable to even
mainstream scientists like go tap.
Exactly,
exactly.
Go back a good ang pedang.
These are apparently a structures that
were buIlt at least 11 or 12,000
years ago.
And I'm waiting to find out the,
um,
the most recent ideas on him.
I think that probably they go back much
older than that because from what graham
told me,
they're just only in the preliminary
stages of being excavated.
So I believe rebecca tempe is less than
10 percent excavated,
right?
Yeah.
So this is this enormous ruined that
appears to be late pleistocene ice age
in an age that apparently was
deliberately buried.
Um,
which is interesting.
Brings up a very interesting issue.
Why would they deliberately buried and
they noticed delivery deliberately
buried because of the uniformity of the
age of the dirt.
Is that when I questioned him on that,
because I wanted to know if it was
because the first thing I thought to
myself was it could be natural because I
have seen so many sedimentary deposits
caused by great floods.
Graham assured me that that was,
that it was human.
It was deliberate.
It was not.
Because if it had been buried by floods,
your water,
there should be internal stratification.
That would be very obvious.
I've been giving it some thought and,
and you know,
what occurred to me was this and,
and I ran this by grand,
but I haven't gotten a response from
them on this,
but I started thinking if it was
deliberately buried,
why would they bury it?
Then I began thinking what we talked
about last time when we were talking
about the tin guscott vanity in siberia
when you had this massive aerial
detonation,
you know,
that was about a 15 megaton explosion.
Okay.
Now that's equivalent to our biggest
hydrogen bombs that used to be in the
american arsenal and it's just because
of an asteroid that,
that blew up in our atmosphere,
but a 150 foot diameter asteroid,
which is not that big really relative
into cosmic scale of things.
The point though is that it was moving
really,
really fast.
You know,
is moving,
you know,
a rifle bullet,
let's say on average it's about a
thousand feet per second.
Write a,
an asteroid coming into the atmosphere
is going to be 20 or 30 times that
velocity,
so it carries an enormous kinetic punch.
when it hits the atmosphere,
it explodes because of the fact that the
earth is not actually absorbing a lot of
that energy.
It's dispersed widely through the
atmosphere.
Now,
think about this particularly during the
height of the cold war,
in order to protect our missile silos
are super hard and command and control
centers.
What did we do with them?
Put them on the ground,
put them under ground.
We buried him.
Exactly,
and that began.
I began to think perhaps could could
explain why it was buried in order to
preserve it against the possibility of,
of some kind of an aerial burst or or
you know,
some kind of a,
a highly energetic event.
That seems a weird thing for 12,000
years ago.
No,
I mean,
what?
What do we have really no evidence
whatsoever that anybody's capable of
doing anything like that that long ago,
but it was.
I think on the contrary,
I think that what we see at the very
beginnings of recorded history,
it's an obsession with the sky,
you know,
and that's one of the points that graham
brings out in his work,
you know,
is that that humans,
our ancestors,
have 10,
12,
13,000,
or even much sooner than that ad had a,
um,
just an obsessive concern where the
vents in the sky and you know,
all of these ancient structures,
whether we're talking about stonehenge
and I'm sure it's going to be the same
case with go beckley,
tappy,
when we look at these,
these,
this infrastructure from the messel
ethic period through the neolithic
period from six,
five,
4,000
years ago,
300 years ago.
What we see is that there's this concern
with astronomy.
You know,
you see the astronomical alignments that
are built into these structures actually
allow some pretty sophisticated,
uh,
observations of,
of events happening in the sky.
And we can maybe pull up some stuff here
that I've brought today to look at.
But,
um,
yeah,
I think that it's highly plausible that
people back then could have.
Because think about this again,
to try to put this in context.
How many generations ago was the primary
mode of human transportation?
Horseback,
not that many,
four or five generations,
and pretty crazy,
pretty crazy.
Now think 7,000
generations.
Are you going to tell me then and all of
that trance,
all of that time,
all of those generations of humans that
have the same presumably intelligences
our own because they've got the same
brain size,
um,
that they're not going to be able to
come up with some kind of a,
uh,
a transmitted tradition,
some type of,
of,
um,
you know,
the idea of somehow of culture,
of civilization,
of language,
of,
uh,
you know,
that's my point is that there was so
much that has been lost.
And once we understand how dynamic this
planet really is,
it'll become clear to us why we don't
have the hard physical record of things
going on 20 or 30,000
years ago.
To put it in perspective for people who
have never studied ancient Egypt.
Cleopatra,
the pyramids of you.
If you look at the date of the pyramids,
that cleopatra is closer to us.
Yes,
than the pyramids were to clear path,
which is nuts.
It's crazy.
Stop and think about that.
Like,
wait a minute,
what was that old back then?
And they have found these little tiny
airplanes inside the pyramids,
these little,
little,
miniature,
you know,
carved airplanes that looked like
airplanes.
If someone's people have tried to saY,
well no,
they represent birds.
That doesn't look like a burden at all.
I mean they have a rudder and they look
like planes.
Well yeah.
And,
and you know,
there are tradItions,
particularly the vedic traditions that
are full of descriptions of flying off.
Yes.
The vimanas yeah,
exactly.
So what is that,
you know,
I'm not going to proclaim unequivocally
it's,
it's airplanes,
but at the same time we got to keep an
open mind about it.
And the point I'm trying to make is that
yeah,
there was so much time to transpired.
All kinds of things could have happened
that have basically been erased.
Right?
And,
and hopefully by the end of today's
interview you'll have a better,
clearer idea of specifically what some
of those things really were.
So we're talking about a potential
civilization of maybe tens of thousands
of years of growth and if we're looking
at what we're,
what we have from the beginning of the
dawn of civilization that we believed
mesopotamia somewhere around 70,000
years ago from that till today,
we're talking about maybe double or
triple that was lost and these gigantic
cataclysmic events may be 15,
20,000,
30,000
years of of human beings inventing
things,
people building upon the inventions of
others expanding and then all of that
wiped out.
We're rubbing sticks together again to
start fires and then whatever memories
are left,
people have to rebuild a generation or
two ago.
It was easy to dismiss.
Ideas like that is fringe science.
Today as we sit here in 2015,
it's not nearly so easy to dismiss that
anymore.
Particularly what we now know about the
history of this planet that are truly
dynamic.
It is bad and that we have in effect
been sort of blessed the last six to
10,000
years were they relatively stable
climate.
And I'm going to show you some graphs
here that really will blow your mind,
that really will,
will,
will underscore how significant some of
these changes have been,
how profound some of them have been.
And once we,
once we know that,
begin to incorporate that into our
thinking,
we realize we're going to have to kind
of reevaluate our models of,
of prehistory.
Okay.
Well we have a new setup now.
So with the tricaster,
we're gonna allow randall to take
control of the situation here.
If you're just listening to this,
this might be one of those podcasts
where if you're one of those people that
listens to it on a commute,
you might want to go back and check out
the,
uh,
well,
vimeo or youtube or those are the ones
that use stream is going to give you a
hd now too,
right?
We do.
Some people don't even know we do a hd
video of this podcast as well.
So what is this oxygen isotopes in
greenland?
oxygen isotopes in greenland.
Yeah.
What we're looking at here,
this goes back to the early nineties
when glaciologists and paleo
climatologist guys should study ancient
climate extracted these ice cores from
the summit of greenland,
and the reason they went to the summit
was because they were looking for the
most undistorted ice core records that
they could find.
previous ice core extractions had been
near the perimeter of the,
of the ice sheets in there.
The ice flow is much more dynamic,
so there was more distortion.
Your record.
So what
they did was they went to the very
center of.
There was a european team and an
american team,
and without getting into the,
into the background,
basically the ice sheet there was almost
two miles thick.
It took them five years to drill
through.
It was miles thick.
Yes.
Yet just think about how far like
looking how far two miles away.
It's like,
what is a plane?
A plane is a mile in the air.
No,
no.
Well,
uh,
is going to be about 30,000
feet.
What's the mile?
Thirty 5,000
feet a mile.
Now human gut.
Remember this,
because it's going to be at number 5,280
feet is a mile is a mile right now the
tallest building in downtown la is
probably not over 800 feet.
Three hundred feet at the most.
No.
Um,
I'm not sure I did look it up at one
point.
What the tallest building was.
I don't remember what,
what it was.
I know the tallest building in atlanta
is a thousand and 60 feet and um,
you know,
two miles,
you'd have to think of 10 of those
stacked on top of each other to get a
two mile thick sheet of ice.
That's,
that's an amazingly huge,
massive ice.
right?
And,
and,
and that's pretty much the summit of
greenland.
right?
And what we're looking at on this,
on this graph here,
if you,
if you go down the left side of the
graph,
this is the surface.
And then down here there's 1500.
You see right at the bottom,
that's 1500 meters,
right?
Fifteen hundred meters.
You figure there's about three point
two,
eight feet per meter.
So that's going to be 45.
It's gonna be close to 5,000.
So this is,
this is 1500 meters.
Tufts aaliyah mile,
yeah,
a little less than a mile over here on
the right is,
is the time in thousands of years before
the present.
So you go down right there,
there's a thousand years,
you go down,
there's 2000 down at the bottom you see
10.
So that's 10,000
years ago.
Now basically what the oxygen isotopes
through there are a proxy for
temperature change adjacent to the ice
mass.
Right?
And if you look at these,
these are snapshots basically taken like
every 10 years.
Right?
And once you see here is that the,
is the temperature is oscillating back
and forth,
back and forth.
It's a two to four degrees centigrade.
Now to put this into context,
the concern,
you know,
we,
we got into this somewhat last time to
hold issue of global warming and,
and I know that in some of the feedback
we got some of the most critical
comments came from people who didn't
like me undermining this whole concept
of global warming induced catastrophe,
right?
What we see here though is was clearly
that the,
that the climate,
this is the 10,000
years that we're talking about here,
it's called the holocene by geologists.
It's oscillating back and forth,
two to four degrees centigrade every,
every 10,
20,
30 years.
Right?
So we're,
we're talking about a degree that has
changed basically in the last century to
the century and a half,
right?
Which,
which really almost wouldn't even show
up here.
You see,
but we're going down as we go down,
we'll see if you go to the right.
That means temperature's warming.
Did you go to the left?
It means it's cooling,
right?
And so as we go back down,
this is through the holocene.
We're going through here and if you
look,
there's some interesting stuff going on
right here at about 8,000,
200 years ago.
There's a really,
there's a spike Of cooling right there.
And that was very,
very significant cooling.
I mean that was probably a,
caused the glaciers worldwide to start
growing again for short,
for a couple of centuries after they had
basically disappeared at the end of the
ice age.
So this was a very significant event
right here,
and then as we get down right here at
10,000,
you see it starts deviating to the left,
it starts deviating to the cooler.
I'm going to go to the next slide.
Where do we take this graph and we turn
it on its side.
And what I've done here is you see this
is,
this is the present right here and this
is basically 10,000
years ago over here on the right side
and,
and I've drawn a level.
There's a level green line in here to
kind of give you a comparison and you'll
notice something.
Here's this 8,000,
200 year ago cold spike,
right?
And then as we're going along here,
you'll notice something that the general
amplitude of these oscillations starts
increasing as we get closer to the
present.
Can you see that?
Yeah,
it gets better.
And you'll also notice that it's
dropping,
it's dropping below that green line and
that means it's cooling.
So in the last 10,000
years,
we went from a period of considerable
warmth in the immediate post glacial
era.
And then it began to cool off around
6,000
years ago,
5,000
and I said,
begin to cool off the temperature.
Oscillations began to increase in
magnitude.
Okay?
Which actually contradicts the computer
models that are saying the amplitude of
the oscillations is going to increase as
the climate gets warmer.
What we actually see from the greenland
ice cores is the opposite of that.
And it's right here in this graph.
But what's really significant about this
is when we go back beyond 10,000
years ago,
whoa.
And we see this jesus christ.
Yeah.
For folks who listening,
there's a giant change.
I mean,
we're looking at a little tiny,
you know,
maybe millimeter left,
right?
Left,
right,
left,
right up until this point.
Now we're looking at huge changes.
Huge changes.
Wow.
Catastrophic changes of temperature.
Yeah.
And,
and here we're going back.
This is notice,
this is between a 11 right here,
roughly 11,600
years ago.
And about 14,000
Look at what happened right here.
You can see right around 15,000
years ago,
the climate is is actually if we took
this thing out of here,
you can see there's almost a a trend
upwards that gets interrupted right
here.
Boom,
instantly,
boom,
overnight jump overnight.
Overnight.
Yeah,
and in fact,
what has happened is if you go back
through the literature of of climate
change and you read the,
the estimates,
how long
it took for the planet to shift modes
from full glacial to the interglacial
like we're now 50,
75 years ago,
it was a thousand or more years,
thousands of years.
When radiocarbon dating came along in
the fifties,
it began to compress and what happened
is that if you look in the eighties,
they're talking about perhaps a century,
several centuries now comes the
greenland ice cores and other ice cores
and other proxies,
deep sea corps and so forth,
and the correlation of all of this
evidence and it goes from centuries,
two decades.
Well,
as the ability to perceive these changes
through with ever greater precision and
ever greater resolution has evolved.
It's gotten to now where the change,
the climate change that took us from
glacial interglacial happened in less
than five years and that's what we're
seeing right here in this graph.
That's what we're seeing.
So 2010 glacier,
2015 done ice age over the glacier.
Yeah.
Bear in mind now that there was a
considerable lag between the actual,
the,
the manifestation of the glaciers
because the glaciers didn't melt that
quick because they're so huge.
Imagine it.
We had a big chunk of ice.
We had an ice sculpture here.
Right?
And if the temperature is 31 degrees,
it's not going to melt.
If you turn the temperature up to 70
degrees,
right?
We could turn the temperature up in the
matter and he could warm up the room in
a matter of hours or minutes.
But it's gonna take a while for that ice
sculpture to melt.
There's going to be a lag,
right?
Although the change that led to that
meltdown was virtually instantaneous.
You see so,
but in that,
in that period,
and it's the interim,
what we're seeing right here,
there was an extraordinary right here.
I think if I go to the next slide,
I think you know,
let's go to the next one.
Yeah.
I'm going to zoom in here so you can see
this.
There were two massive warming spikes.
One right here,
you can see that we're down here in full
glacial mode right there.
And then boom,
right there.
There's huge spike of,
of warming.
Now what does that represent when it
comes to like temperatures?
Uh,
that could be on the order of.
Well,
that would be about 10 to 12 degrees
centigrade,
which would be about 18 degrees
fahrenheit.
Average temperature,
which is a crazy,
crazy,
crazy change because they're scared of
two degrees,
right?
Scared of two degrees.
And here we're looking,
we're scared to tutorees centigrade
here.
We're looking at five,
six times that much in a matter of a
couple of years.
You'll see at this point,
we don't really have an explanation for
this.
That's why I get really frustrated when
somebody says to me,
oh,
the debate on climate change is over.
No,
no,
we're,
we're in the infancy of understanding
the climate of this planet.
And when we look at stuff like this,
you see,
um,
it really drives home that point.
And you can see here,
right here people,
people are saying when they're saying
that the debate on climate change is
over though,
is whether or not human beings have had
an impact on it in current times.
No question.
We have had an impact.
No question of what the debate is.
Right?
Well,
if you say that the debate is about have
humans had an impact or not,
I think that there is no debate.
Yeah.
Humans have had an impact.
What they're looking at though in your
mind is one aspect of a very
multidimensional issue.
Yes.
Yes,
exactly,
exactly.
And,
and my,
my concern is,
is that we're going to get so focused on
carbon chains and carbon chains that
we're not looking at any of these other
factors.
Isn't that what people do though?
We concentrate on one aspect of things
and it becomes like almost like a
cultural meme and that it spreads.
And this is all people talk about.
It had been so many people.
I guarantee you that we're upset at what
you said have not researched climate
change at all.
They just have parroted the words of
people that they've heard on television
that are experts.
Well,
you got this.
97 percent agree.
Well,
if you look into the origin of that,
it's pretty contrived.
It really is.
I mean,
how you come up with that and,
and we could do an hour long discussion
on dan.
I don't really think we want to get into
that today,
but I,
I really feel like I should write an
analysis of that.
The source of that 97 percent so called
consensus so that people can really see
where it came from.
In a nutshell.
Basically it goes to three or four
pieces of research.
Some surveys that went out that were
slanted right from the beginning.
It's such as a.
Do you feel that humans have an impact
on climate?
Yes.
Nobody disagrees with that.
So you can go through all the whoever
these so-called deniers are.
I have looked and looked.
Who's,
who's denying?
Is there any climate scientists on any
anywhere on the spectrum that denies
that the climate changes or that denies
that humans have had an influence on the
climate and I haven't found a single
one.
So in other words,
these deniers that you hear about,
you know,
the climate change deniers,
they don't really exist.
There are those who criticize the
consensus view,
right?
That the dominant mode of climate change
is being induced by humans and they are
being shoved into this camp of climate
change deniers,
but they're not.
They're absolutely not climate change
deniers.
And when you look at it,
stuff like this,
you know,
a lot of these guys who would question
the so called anthropogenic climate
change consensus are guys who have done
this work.
Now this work is how old?
How?
Well,
let's go.
This goes to the.
This goes back to the,
to these are the,
this work that I'm showing you here.
It was published in [inaudible] 93.
The,
the,
the greenland ice sheet project and the,
the greenland ice sheet project into
greenland.
Oh,
I forget it was grip and just the two.
It was a european and an american team.
They five years drilling,
so these are the most accurate proxies.
We have it in hand and they're pulling
tubes of ice is just like a cylinder.
Yeah,
like cylinders picture maybe six inches
in diameter,
so they have like a circular cutting
thing and they have a circular cutting
drill that extracts these ice cores and
for the last 20 years they've been
analyzing the ice core,
you know,
it took five years to get them out and
it's been 20 years now of analyzing what
they're telling us.
So before they had all these ice cores,
when they were saying that this climate
change took thousands of years,
was that just guessing?
Pretty much based.
That was based upon actual empirical
observations of ice glaciers receding as
a result of the modern warming because
you have to understand up until about
the middle of the 19th century,
we were in the middle of what was has
commonly been referred to as the little
ice age.
And,
and this is another thing that's
important to put into context.
The ice.
The little ice age was in two phases.
the earliest phase came on in about the
mid 13 hundreds,
then it warmed for about a century into
15,
16 hundreds,
and then the second phase came on.
During that time,
the glaciers worldwide began to grow,
and most of the evidence today suggests
that during the little ice age,
glaciers were bigger than they had been
in 10,000
years.
So around the middle of the 19th
century,
around 1850,
give or take,
a decade or two,
the climate began to warm out of the
little ice age and glaciers began to
receive.
Right now,
if we look at glacier recession that's
going on right now,
and it's been going on for the last 10
or 20 years,
what we see is it's basically a
continuation of the recession.
It's been going on for 160 or 170 years.
Right?
So it's important to establish what's
our baseline when we're comparing modern
recession of glaciers.
Bear in mind that our baseline is we're
starting from the glaciers being bigger
than they had been in 10,000
years.
Right?
So the.
I think then we have to understand that
that that little ice agent in fact had
some pretty serious consequences for
civilization.
We can see that there were two period in
the last 2000 years.
There were two periods of of global
cooling.
One of them occurred in the sixth
century.
It actually now can be accurately dated
to occurring between 5:36
and 5:44
a d,
which is a very interesting time.
This was basically the time that
historians have have for for decades
said this was the onset of the dark
ages.
It's also the time during which all of
the arthurian myths and the grail quest
stories are placed.
You know arthur arthur,
his desk death is,
is traditionally placed at the battle of
cam land or cam lawn,
which is usually dated at about five a
which,
which basically culminated this quest
for the grail.
Right.
WhAt was the other grail?
Stories themselves were,
were set down in writing between about
1130 and 1230 d in this really
interesting time during the middle ages.
At the same time that the great
cathedrals were being built.
When the cath,
our movement was at its strongest when
tonight knights of the temple were at
their strongest,
um,
when cobble ism schools were flourishing
in Spain,
when the troubadours we're making their
circuits around europe,
uh,
you know,
spreading news and entertainment,
but really probably carrying a esoteric
information to the initiates that had
the key to the,
to the secret language that they use
there.
It was very interesting time,
but it was in that 12,
82,
1130 to 1230,
that the,
that,
the grail stories were written down.
Now the grail stories actually refer
back to this period of the arthurian
days,
and the quest for the grail,
if you recall,
was that the,
that the land had succumbed to blight.
It had become a wasteland.
England who had become a wasteland.
And the idea of the grail was it was the
grail not only restored the wasteland
restored the king,
because remember the king,
whether it was king arthur or braun,
or on toss or the fisher king,
there were different names and different
stories.
It was the same deal.
He was sick,
he was in decline.
He was wounded,
the wound wouldn't heal,
he was debilitated,
and the only way to restore him was to
find the grail,
bring the grail back,
allowing to drink from the grail,
but the grail was also the means of
restoring the wasteland to fertility and
fecundity.
Now,
here's where it gets interesting,
is that the dendro chronologists who who
studied tree rings have been looking at
that period exactly in that period that
the,
that the tradition places,
the grail quest and have discovered that
for about eight or 10 years,
forest growth in the northern hemisphere
almost came to a screeching halt.
And this is now been well documented.
Mike bailey,
who's has done most of this work,
I'm basically showing that there was a
serious global cooling that took place
during those years.
And the historical record of that seems
to confirm because there's multiple
descriptions from irish monks and saw on
describinG how for weeks at a time the
sun is not visible,
that you know,
that it's darkness has come over tHe
land,
that there were reports of these
mysterious fogbugz and then there are
multiple collapses of agriculture.
Okay?
So,
uh,
as a result of these multiyear collapses
of agriculture because of the cold and
the dark and damp,
um,
people got malnourished and then you had
famine as a result of famine.
People be there,
their immune systems became weakened.
And then in five,
42 a d,
you had the onset of the justinian
plague,
which wiped out maybe a third of the
population of europe.
Whole whole villages disappeared as a
consequence.
Now these events pretty much followed in
sequence.
You see,
the cold brought about the collapse of
agriculture.
The collapse of agriculture brought
about famine.
Famine brought about weakness.
And as a result,
boom you have flag.
Now it took european civilization nearly
three centuries to recover from that.
Now what brought about the recovery was
the return of warmth to the world,
what is called the medieval warm period.
And between this began really to occur
in about 900 add this sea ice began to
retract back well inside the arctic
circle,
which opened up the sea lanes between
northern europe,
Iceland,
and greenland.
And so it was this period of time that
the,
that the,
that the vikings were able to sail to
Iceland and then sailed to greenland and
actually establish a colonies on the
west coast of greenland,
greenland,
and farm or the.
Now the ground is perennially
perennially frozen.
Let me try that again.
Per yeley frozen,
right?
So it was clearly a warm period.
And what happened was,
if you look back now at the studies from
that medieval warm period,
you see that agriculture rebounded
suddenly.
People had lots of food to eat.
I'm actually studies of skeletons show
that the stature of humans during this
period of time increased by four or five
inches on average from what it had been
during the dark ages.
And I'm now europe started becoming
wealthy because the basis of all wealth
basically was,
was agriculture was food,
right?
Without that,
you don't have anything else.
Population began to expand enormously.
You see other things going on.
Um,
lifespans increase,
a infant mortality decrease.
All of this stuff has been well
documented in a whole variety of
studies.
Well,
after about a century and a half of this
warmth with the,
with the concomitant wealth that came
along,
european society was wealthy enough to
undertake this extraordinary cathedral
building phase.
You see where you had literally hundreds
of thousands of highly trained,
highly skilled crafts people working on
these things.
You had essentially,
when you begin to look at the cathedral
building phenomenon,
it required the basically the
mobilization of of the whole of european
society behind this enterprise,
because you had to cory mounts of stone,
you had to transport these stones,
you had the car of the stones,
you look at the statuary,
the stain glass,
which is exceptional,
and it's in its refractive properties
that really have still not been mimicked
to this day.
The way the stained glass was able to
refract light so that it gives the
appearance of of not the light coming
shining through the glass,
but emanating from within the glass and
you could go on and on with this.
ThE,
the,
the carpentry scaled,
the engineering skill,
the astronomy that went into these
structures.
All of this combined basically shows up
basically in historical instant and in
what's interesting is the scarcity of,
of evidence showing what proceeded this.
How did these,
who organized this,
who raised the money,
who trained the craftsman,
you know,
this is,
there are,
there are references to this in history,
but really,
you know,
there's no explicit detailed discussion
where we can go and trace it and say,
okay,
this is,
this is how it happened.
You know,
but it's important to realize that this
was a consequence of the,
uh,
of the,
you know,
the expansion of,
of,
of wealth in european society that,
that was able to allow this to happen.
And that's as a consequence of the
warmth,
the warmth of the earth.
And what we see is that the cathedral
building era comes to a sudden
termination in nearly 13 hundreds.
And if you Go on your travel around a
cathedrals,
you'll find that there is,
in many cases,
you know,
the record suggests that it's almost as
if in the middle of their work,
the workman laid down their tools and
left in some cases.
And this is why there were so many
cathedrals of the great ones that
weren't finished.
Okay.
but what you see is that exactly
concurring with the cessation of
cathedral building within a day,
within a few decades anyway,
was the onset to the little ice age and
the return of the cold and this first
phase of the little ice age again
brought about agricultural collapses at
brought about famine.
And then you had the black plague that
showed up,
I think around,
whAt was it?
13 slash 30 slash 1340 right in there
again,
decimated the civilization of europe.
So you can see,
I mean if we look at the historical
record,
what we see is the times of,
of global warming have actually been
times of advancement in civilization.
Now,
of course,
That there,
that would have its limit.
I mean we could get to,
you know,
at some point where we would get too
warm in yours.
But so far what we've seen,
we're at this point well within the
range of natural variability.
That's the why is this never brought up
by anybody but you.
I've never heard anybody else discuss
this,
this very controversial subject.
It's controversial because everyone's so
fixated on global warming being a bad
thing.
It's there.
It's there for anybody who is willing to
do their homework,
you know,
and if somebody goes on my website or
whatever and says,
what are your sources?
I'm glad to provide multiple,
multiple sources going back.
I've been,
I've been collecting this data for
decades,
you know,
and it's there and I have to ask the
same question.
Why are we ignoring this evidence?
You know,
why are we.
Well,
the,
I think we're ignoring it because
climate change has become a political
agenda rather rather than a scientific
question,
you know,
and so because there are political
factions that are lined up behind it.
Um,
you know,
the inner intergovernmental panel on
climate change is now looked at as being
the ultimate source for data on,
on the climate.
And bear in mind,
they were created by the united nations
framework convention on climate change
and given the mandate of go out there
and demonstrate that humans are causing
climate change.
So right from the very start,
that was their mission.
And they were not told go and look for
natural causes of natural climate
variability,
study the human and.
And it's important and I mean I'm not at
all saying it's not important for us to
study our own effects on climate,
but it's going to be dangerous.
I think if,
if we neglect,
you know,
what we're seeing right here on these
graphs or this graph that I'm showing
you because that's clearly not carbon
dioxide.
See if we're told,
and we have been repeatedly told that
carbon dioxide concentrations in the
atmosphere held relatively steady at
about 280 parts per million,
right?
Prior to the industrial revolution and
only subsequent to the industrial
revolution.
Did cArbon dIoxide start going up?
Well,
if we assume just for the sake of
argument that,
that.
That's correct.
We'll look at this graph.
What we're saying is that if carbon
dioxide held steady at 280 parts per
million going back hundreds of thousands
of years as al gore is actually stated,
and as many others have stated,
it's not carbon dioxide driving those
climate changes,
is it?
well,
it can't be that it can't be new.
if that's the case,
and that's hard science,
this is hard science,
right?
It's hard science as well.
You're.
You're looking at something really
crazy.
Some event.
Yeah.
That's my point.
Now the alternative is,
okay,
are we saying if,
if,
if carbon dioxide is the dominant driver
of climate change and that's what we're
seeing here,
then what that basically says is that
there is some gigantic unknown
reservoirs of co two that have outgassed
into the atmosphere,
which again undermines the so called
consensus view because so far the
consensus view,
the consensus view states that the ceo
has only increased because of burning
fossil fuel.
So this graph is the real inconvenient
truth.
This graph that's well put.
Yes,
this graph is the real inconvenient
truth and when we look at some of this,
I mean right there,
that is a major global warming right
there because this dashed line
represents the modern temperature like
the date,
the 20th century average is this dash
line,
that dash line.
What year are we looking at?
Right there,
right here.
This is between 100 and 150,000
years ago,
and that's a giant jump.
That's a gIant joe.
I mean,
so what,
what does that represent as far as
degrees in temperature?
Oh,
well,
let's
see.
That's probably going to be,
you know,
15 to 18 degrees fahrenheit.
Whoa.
Yeah,
right there.
So that's,
you know,
again,
15 to 18 times greater than the,
than the,
the presumed temperature increase of the
last century.
Is there any mainstream,
I shouldn't say mainstream scientific
explanation for what that is?
No.
Well,
it's called the eemian called the eemian
periods in interglacial period,
but even within the interglacial period,
you see that there are these massive
oscillations,
massive cooling,
cooling and warming again.
Yeah.
And so there's a variability if you're
saying the warming is between it's 18
degrees.
That what you said to up to that.
So the cooling,
you're talking about almost that much in
the other direction.
The other direction.
Yeah.
And who you're talking about this over a
period of just a few decades.
Well,
as we get back this far,
we don't have the same degree of
precision is we do when we're,
we're here.
um,
perhaps yes,
but we were not sure,
but we do know that these changes that
we're looking at here,
the terminated the last ice age.
We're just in a matter of a few years.
Yeah,
for sure.
And the instantaneous nature of those is
what you focus on when you start talking
about asteroidal impacts and things
along those lines of that is something
that we can explain.
It's something you can point to by
default.
There doesn't seem to be a lot of other
things that we can invoke to explain
what we're seeing right here.
And there's absolute evidence that we
have been hit multiple times.
We're going to get into that.
Yes,
yes.
And,
and that's a big part of what,
what graham's book is going to be
amazing.
when you look at the ancient history,
I mean it's not even ancient as far as
me and they were human beinGs living
sort of like us,
but how much different the climate was
like,
it was so fucked up.
Well,
I'm not sure about the west coast,
but I know on the east coast there were,
you know,
swarms of icebergs stranding,
like off the coast of South Carolina,
for example,
you know,
there was no great lakes because of the
great lakes were under thousands of feet
of ice,
you know,
New York,
boston,
detroit,
um,
seattle,
portland,
or not sort of a portland,
but seattle,
twin cities,
chicago.
All of these areas were under thousands
of feet of ice,
thousands of feet.
And we're not talking millions of years
ago.
We're talking 12,
13,000
to 25 to 30,000
years ago.
That's incredible.
It is.
And,
and sea levels were basically in round
numbers,
400 feet lower than now,
which essentially exposes the entire
con.
Most of the continental shelves.
And I'm going to,
I've got some,
some interesting graphics here to show
you,
uh,
what,
what continental coastlines would have
looked like.
There was an article that I was reading
recently about aborigines in aboriginal
tales of,
uh,
of the lowered,
like lowered levels
that they're starting to correspond now
with actual climate data and
understanding of what the sea levels
actually war at that time.
And these are stories that are
supposedly 10,000
years old pass through oral traditions.
These traditions to me are just beyond
valuable,
you know,
up until very recently they have been
considered basically just,
you know,
interesting in the,
in the,
in the anthropological or psychological
sense,
but had no real hard scientific
credibility to them.
Now I think we're beginning to
reevaluate them near as an archeologist,
this archeologist by the name of Bruce
Massey,
who's been doing some very interesting
work in for the last 20 years analyzing,
uh,
many of these ancient myths and
realizing and putting out there the
argument that these,
that these myths and these legends in
these epic tales a code really hard
scientific information that we could
extract from them.
And I'm talking about global changes and
astronomical events and so forth.
And,
and um,
so,
and I've been a believer in that for a
long time,
you know,
and this is one of the premises of
graham's work is that,
that the myths and the legends actually
have a great deal to teach us beyond
just the psychological orientation of
our ignorant pre-scientific ancestors,
you know.
But yeah,
a good point you make there.
Um,
when we look at this graph,
basically what we're seeing here is that
coming out of the ice age,
you can kind of see that we're coming up
here and then we have this massive spike
of warming and then it seesaws back down
into this full glacial cold.
This is called this period between these
two green arrows is called the younger
dryas,
which is named after a polar wildflower
that had disappeared in northern europe
and then suddenly came back again.
It only grows in polar environments,
a dry us octa patella.
So the younger dryas compared because
there was an older darius too,
but it lasted.
Now the dates are placing it from
roughly 12,000,
900 years ago,
give or take a few decades to 11,600
years ago.
So this spike of warming right here is
11,600
years.
Now,
if we look at the next one here,
this graph basically goes to a different
realm of evidence.
and what this shows is the average,
the rate of sea level rise.
You see now oceanographers marine
geologists have been studying.
There'S,
there's a number of dIfferent ways they
can correlate this information.
They can look at actual evidence of
submerged shorelines,
right?
They can look at changes in the,
in the flora and the fauna that have,
that have lived in the oceans.
They can look at coRal reefs.
Uh,
there's a lot of different things that
they can pull together to see how
rapidly sea levels rose at the end of
the last ice age and again,
generation or two ago.
The assumption was is that there was a
smooth continuum of rise that took tens
of thousands of years,
right?
To get us from minus 400 feet up to what
we are now.
At the present level,
what this graph shows is that there were
two massive spikes of meltwater
introduced into the oceans,
into the global oceans at the end of the
last ice age,
and you can see The first spike called
meltwater pulse one a is the biggest
followed by another one,
meltwater pulse one b.
If we go back to this graph right here,
those two spikes of glacial melt water
and sea level rise coincided with this
warming spike and net warming spike,
and you can see how this warming spike
seems to be the most intense followed by
this one.
And we see that meltwater pulse one a is
the biggest.
So what this is showing is that the,
that the rise in sea level was not as
smooth.
It was like,
whoa.
And then warm up again.
So there was something that caused all
those glaciers to melt within just a
very short amount of time.
A geologically speaking,
yes,
a geological instant.
Exactly.
What's further interesting is when we
look at this graph,
this is the late pleistocene mortality
graph,
and each square represents a fossil
specimen of an extinct mammal.
You know,
could be a woolly mammoth,
could be a giant ground sloth,
could be a saber tooth cat,
could be the giant cave bear roughly 120
species of mega mammals that lived
during the ice age when extinct right at
the end of the ice age in basically what
this graph is showing us here is that
you probably can't read this here,
so oh interpreted for you.
if you go back to here,
the left side represents 50,000
years ago and here were where the cursor
is.
That's 40,000
years,
30,000,
20,000,
and you see that as we're going along
here.
Each one of these squares represents the
finding of a fossil,
of an extinct mammal in the,
in the fossil record.
What we see from this graph is that when
we get to between 11 and 13,000
years ago,
there's a massive spike of calendar
shoots through the roof.
This demise of these animals directly
coincided directly coincides with this
right here directly.
Now what we,
what we're dealing with is that for 50
years the dominant theory has been,
is called overkill or blitzkrieg and
this theory basically states that bands
have paleo.
Indian hunters came across the bering
land bridge,
slaughtering every animal that they
encountered along the way and somehow
within less than a thousand years,
swept from siberia down to tierra del
fuego and killed off every willie,
every man within the world,
and presumably every other of the
extinct mammals.
And that has been the dominant theory
that,
that humans caused this mass extinction.
And personally I think that's just
absurd because for one thing,
based upon anthropological studies,
there were possibly more wooly mammoths
in the world and there were people for
awhile.
Um,
you know,
you have to assume that the blitz creek
was so instantaneous and so all
encompassing that there was no time even
for the mammas to,
to reproduce.
Of course,
the overkill hypothesis basically
addresses itself only to Willie May or
only to mammoths.
Wooly mammoths were one species of four
different species of mammals.
But what about the other roughly 120
species?
What about the,
the giant armadillos into a giant
beavers in the american place to see
lion that was as big as big as a horse.
Uh,
You know,
the list goes on and on and on and on in
these animals all basically disappeared
during this spike that you see right
here.
And that spike faults exactlY between
these two warming spikes and between the
two sea level rises.
So all the data,
all points that same time period.
Yes.
Wow.
And so what I'm saying,
and this is,
this is,
uh,
you know,
basically consistent with what graham
singh and his book is that,
this,
what we're seeing here,
this episode basically represents a
curtain that has come down and obscured
150,000
or more years of deep human history and
basically his last that history to
modern perception.
But now once we understand that,
yeah,
you know what the uniformitarians were
wrong to reject all ideas of
catastrophism,
you know,
because in the original,
in the early days of geology,
the,
the founding fathers of geology,
we're catastrophists.
They went out in the field unencumbered,
unencumbered,
unencumbered by dogmas and doctrines.
And so forth,
they looked at the evidence in the field
and concluded that there had been
catastrophic episodes.
And this is a baron von qva,
sedgwick murchison,
if you'd go back and you're all of these
guys who basically are considered the
godfathers of modern geology,
they were to a man catastrophist,
uh,
james hutton,
lyle and play fair came along and
basically proposed the idea of
uniformitarianism.
The present is the key to the past.
Very powerful.
A working idea is that we can look at
stuff that's going on today,
extrapolate backwards and try to figure
out things that happened in the past
when we don't have an eyewitness
account.
Right?
Very powerful.
But what,
what happened was it became so
entrenched as dogma that anybody who
invoked catastrophes was considered,
um,
basically fringe.
Because in the early days,
some of these guys like sedgwick,
for example,
he was a theologian.
He was a traveling minister who went
around and in his travels to convert
that,
the people to,
to christianity,
he would see the stuff and he would,
you know,
place it within the context perhaps of
being noah's flood,
right?
And they would place it in some of,
not all of them,
some of them would place it in a,
in a biblical context.
Right?
So when they were attacked,
basically the,
the substance of the attack was,
well you guys are trying to bring us
back to the days of biblical literalism
in sciences.
Moved beyond that.
We're not here,
we don't want to talk about catastrophes
or great floods.
Dahlias weren't.
We're through talking about all of that.
That's all been discredited.
And what you see is between the early 18
hundreds with the beginning of geology,
earth science too,
about the 19th century,
what you see as a steady decline,
you know,
some of the older guys die off,
they're replaced by the new guys who
have now basically taken control of the
university curriculums.
And they been indoctrinated into this
idea of a strict gradUalism.
And at any deviation from that strict
gradualism is,
is a heresy basically.
So by the time we get to the 20th
century,
you had this raining uniformity,
raining gradualists dogma that had been
imposed upon all earth science.
And anybody who deviated from that was
immediately kicked out of the club.
And this is why when jay harlan brett's
came along in the 19 twenties and
proposed that there had been these
gigantic floods in the pacific
northwest,
you know,
the geological community basically said,
get outta here.
We don't want to hear aBout it.
We know that that couldn't have been
just because we know jay harlan brett's
continued to document,
exhaustively document from the field
that,
that these floods were very real.
His critics said,
well,
you don't,
you can't provide a source for these
floods.
Therefore they didn't happen.
Now,
bear in mind that all of his critics is
his most vocal critics had never even
gone out to actually look right.
And a gram is going to hit.
It's got a great section in his new
upcoming book describing the,
the ordeal that brett's was put through.
But he finally prevailed of ultimately,
um,
most of his critics died off,
you know,
he outlived and he lived to be,
I think 98.
So I think when he was 96,
he was given the penrose metal,
which is the highest honor of geology
and the only,
he said he was very grateful,
but the only thing he he was unhappy
about was the fact that he,
all of his critics had died off.
So he didn't get to gloat over.
So.
But,
um,
but so What happened was you had the
younger geologists come in who are,
who are more open to that in,
in what you see is between the fifth,
19,
15 and 19 sixties.
You have a transition going on where
we're,
where they're beginning to accept that
these great floods that happened.
But,
but what they did was they took a modern
example,
which is glacial outburst floods,
which we've witnessed dozens and dozens,
probably hundreds of suitcases in
Iceland,
particularly Alaska,
british columbia of the himalayas where
you have particularly going back to the
little ice age.
When the glaciers began to recede in the
mid 19th century,
you had a lot of what are called pro
glacial lakes formed or lakes bodies of
water held in by the melting ice.
And then eventually the ice gave way
into the water,
rushed out in the form of a flood.
The icelanders call it a yoke elopes.
Okay,
so we have a modern example.
So what they did was in the sixties and
seventies was they said,
okay,
guess what?
We've got now evidence that there was a
huge body of water,
huge lake in western Montana,
and it was held in by an ice dam.
That ice dam gave way all of this water
gushed out over Idaho and in
southeastern Washington down to columbia
gorge to the pacific ocean,
and caused all of these,
this amazing erosion and sedimentation
that harland brett's was documenting.
Never mind that we have to extrapolate
up three orders of magnitude from modern
examples,
right?
Nevermind,
that the modern examples are utterly
minuscule compared to what brett's was
looking at.
That has become the dogma to explain
these floods and it's still the
entrenched dogma as we speak.
Now I am trying to demolish that dogma.
I want to show that these floods were
something much grander than they have
even imagined,
and that the source of him was not
actually a big glacial lake,
but was,
was what brett's originally originally
theorized was that there was something
that caused a rapid melting of the ice.
But then his critics said,
well,
there's nothing that could melt the ice
as fast as you're requiring for your
floods.
So again,
your floods didn't happen,
but his floods did happen and they were
on an enormous inconceivably vast scale.
And this is what I was taking him out to
see firsthand because I felt like for
him to,
to really have a handle on this,
uh,
this information and this,
this insight into the catastrophes that,
that basically would have terminated his
mother civilization as he called it,
that he should see this stuff in the
field for himself.
Because,
you know,
as they say,
a picture's worth a thousand words.
We're going out in the field and
experiencing this directly is worth a
thousand pictures.
And,
and so he's going to incorporate that
into his,
into his book.
And I would like to say about that book,
that that,
based upon what I know and what you've
shown me,
a bit of what's going into the book I'll
I'll proclaim without any equivocation
that I think is probably going to be the
most important book that's come out in a
21st century because it's opening a
window onto this story,
like no other single source of
information.
CredIble information.
Wow,
that's a big.
It's a big statement.
This,
this whole thing is so mind blowing and
as mind blowing as your first
appearances.
This chart especially is really freaking
me out.
Like looking at the mortality,
all the animals,
the mass extinction event that must have
taken place.
One of the things that always bothered
me about that idea that human beIngs
killed off the wooly mammoths is that
they found these vast fields of uneaten
mammoths where there was thousands of
them that had died almost
instantaneously,
which is just.
That doesn't make any sense.
Like what did they do?
They went on a mass killing orgy of
slaughter and then just decided not to
eat any of them.
Well,
you know,
the field evidence itself is
inconsistent with that idea right here.
This is an example.
This is one of the many mammoth
cemeteries and and what happens is that
you can see here that you can see from
the shoreline seated,
there was a flood,
the river rose up to this level,
and then when it rolls down,
it left this in its wake.
And what you see here like this is bone
counting at the barrel mammoth cemetery
in northern yakutia siberia.
Identical deposits are found throughout
the tamer peninsula in what we see here
is these massive bone deposits that have
been showing up for the last couple of
hundred years.
Every time that there's a thawing or a
flood or these things are washed up on
the shore of the arctic ocean.
You know what we see is that there were
huge,
huge herds of wooly mammoths grazing.
We're now the plant material is only two
inches high.
So clearly it was a completely different
climate there.
You know,
what's interesting is that you,
you had in siberia able to support herds
of wooly mammoths at the same time that
half of north America is buried under
two miles or more advice.
How is that possible?
Just a totally different atmosphere.
Still puzzling over that.
I have some ideas,
but until I can test these ideas a
little further.
Um,
so without an ice core samples,
is it impossible to figure out what the
temperature was in siberia at that time?
No,
no.
They configure out basically based upon
fossil plant remains.
And you can see that in some cases the
tree line was hundreds of miles further
north than it is now.
An ex.
Clearly if you've got trees,
forests growing now were 13 or 14 or
15,000
years ago.
It was permafrost,
you know,
it was warmer clearly.
So there's still.
Whoa.
What does that 19th century scene
showing every floor of the london docks
covered by thousands of mammoth tusks
from siberia.
This is a drawing obviously,
pre dates,
photographs,
yeah.
For hundreds of years,
thousands of mammas in tombed,
mammoth and mammoth tusks were being
zoomed from the siberian permafrost.
Thousands and thousands and thousands of
these.
And,
and basically
to me,
you look at this,
this is just in your face evidence that
this was not humans doing this,
you know,
it was not humans that were,
were slaughtering these mammas and
burying near remains it,
it the instantaneous nature would
almost.
It would almost be like people have
figured out some new thing,
like they figured out some,
some like,
uh,
a doom gun,
you know,
where they shot the whole,
the doom got well,
look at,
look at the near extinction of american
bison.
What brought that about trains and high
powered rifles,
right?
It was a technological major,
technological advancement that was able
to bring about the near extermination of
the american,
especially a guy that I'm going to bring
on the podcast soon to discuss that.
As name's dan flores,
who spent a big chunk of his
intellectual career studying this.
And what he believes is that the bison
had a massive population jump that was
directly correlating to smallpox
epidemic.
The native american people and that when
the United States,
when we look at the United States
history in the big stacks of woolly
mammoths,
or excuse me,
the big stacks of bison skulls,
we always look to like that was a very
unusual population of bison that existed
because the plains indians had
experienced this massive extinction
event and then when they had
incorporated the horse like the horse
and the.
Apparently the american indians,
native americans rather were on their
way to extra padding the bison even
before we came along.
But then they died off in this massive
death scenario with small pox and all
the different diseases that the
europeans had brought over here.
And then the mammoth population,
or excuse me,
the bison population had grown like
almost unnaturally.
It'd been much larger than it ever been
in the past and that's when the United
States was established and that's when
all the western european immigrants had
come along and started killing off all
these bisons.
It's really a very interesting subject
and it's an interesting idea.
It's plausible.
I haven't looked into that.
You know,
I,
I just assumed,
and maybe maybe wrongfully,
but I had assumed that the bison
population had been relatively stable.
I am not convinced though,
that,
that there was this massive die off of
the native american population yet I'm
not convinced maybe,
well,
because I haven't looked into it yet,
but,
but you know,
one of the things I've seen is that the
assumption there is predicated upon the
europeans arrived and brought the
diseases that,
that,
uh,
that native americans had no defenses
for.
But the thing is,
is that,
you know,
there's so much evidence now showing
that there were lots of explorers in
immigrants
to the new world prior to the arrival of
the europeans.
You know,
the chinese,
the phoenicians.
And I'm not necessarily saying that's
credible that none of it's been proven.
But there's some interesting data out
there that suggests in there a number of
books written that again,
I haven't accessed it.
So I'm not gonna sit here and pretend
that I'm an authority on that because
I'm not.
But,
but if some of that turns out to be
credible,
it would suggest that there was a lot
more interaction between the native
american population and other groups
around the world,
which,
if true to me kind of somewhat
undermines this idea that they were,
you know,
completely susceptible to the
introduction of these,
you know,
to these foreign diseases.
But again,
I will,
I've got an open mind.
I'll wait and see.
I'd like to see what his,
what he says,
I'd like to hear his,
his,
uh,
his idea
for anyone interested in.
He has a paper in the journal of
american history.
It's called bison ecology and bison
diplomacy.
The southern plains from 1800 to 1850.
Um,
I just looked for it online.
You can,
there's a preview that's available,
but to download the entire paper or
book,
I'm not sure which one it is.
It's $19.
And what's,
what journal is it in the journal of
american history from september of
[inaudible] 91.
And like I said,
he's working on a new book right now and
uh,
I'm trying to get them to come in,
but it's just,
it's very difficult while he's in the
middle of a,
you said september of 1991.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I can probably access dan flores is his
name.
And uh,
well just the information that I got
about it was pretty mind blowing,
but a sounds interesting.
I want to know more.
Thank you for that.
Joe,
please.
Now let's,
let's go back to that photo that you
have on your desktop that you were going
to explain to me,
but we decided not to talk about it
before the podcast because it's so
incredible that you said this.
All this incredible change that we're
looking at the,
the,
the geological structure,
all that took place within just a week.
Yeah.
Let's go to.
This will,
will come.
I've got that world will come to that.
This is a,
this is a satellite photograph taken
from about 500 miles up.
And what you see here,
this is southeastern Washington,
and what you're looking at here is part
of what's called the columbia basalt
plateau.
This is part of the terrain that,
that we crossed when I was with graham.
What you see here is that you have an
area of,
if you look here,
you can see the,
um,
oh,
differentiate between the pixels in the
actual squares that like,
you see this red area down here is area
that's actually being farmed and it's an
in because this is an photograph.
And so what happens is,
is that the areas that are being
cultivated will show up warmer than the
surrounding areas.
this is,
this whole plateau is covered in this
stuff called los l o e s s,
and it's a type of very fertile soil
that has a rather mysterious and
controversial origin.
We'll get into that right now,
but in some places,
this last layer is hundreds of feet
thIck,
over a dark basalt bedrock that is the
result of,
of these massive outflows of basaltic
lava,
uh,
that,
that came out,
did extruded between about $6 million
and 16 million years ago.
Right.
The,
the hotspot,
that was the ultimate origin of this
basalt is now we're yellowstone is
which,
so you can make that connection near the
yellowstone super volcano.
Super volcano.
Yeah.
In,
in,
um,
but what you have here is that you have
the lighter areas is where this lust
topsoil still exists and the darker
areas is where the,
the,
the underlying dark basalt has been,
is showing through because the loss was
washed away.
So what this is,
is,
is your typical,
the geological term is and nasda
moseying and basically that means a
branching flow pattern of the water and
you can see that very clearly here that
the water came off of this river,
which is the columbia river up here and
float over the landscape and washed away
the basalt and left these gigantic
channels in its wake and there's more
over here to the,
to the east and there's more over here
to the west.
Um,
and if we look at actually this,
let me go to a different program here.
I think that will actually have some
that actually I think has the picture in
it that you were seeing.
Now what we're looking at here is what's
been called the missoula flood,
right?
Named after the town of missoula,
Montana.
Missoula is in a basin that was part of
this hypothesized giant lake that that
presumably caused this flood.
Right.
And again,
there was an ice dam that there was this
ice dam,
the ice dam broke and as soon as this
thing comes up,
I will be able to show you some slides.
Here we go.
Let's see.
here we go.
It's becoming operate here.
While that's coming up,
we'll look at this slide right here
because this will kind of give you a,
a picture of the earth as it was during
the height of the ice age.
So wow,
that's pretty deep.
The sheets of ice go pretty far down.
That's amazing.
Canada didn't exist.
Candidate in exist.
Wow.
Yeah.
Poor canadians.
Well yeah.
And you know,
and you know,
the ice part of it is,
you know,
a lot of that in the midwest now.
A lot of the farming belt of America is
basically growing out of the fertile
soil that the ice scraped off of Canada
and dumped down in Minnesota and Iowa
and Wisconsin and so on.
So,
um,
you know,
some day they may want that back,
but we're not going to let him have it.
It's fascinating when you look at that,
that there was this big ice cap,
but then the areas around it,
no ice and why,
why was that?
Well,
that's one of the mysteries,
again,
like over here in siberia can see over
here,
this is where all the woolly mammoths
were.
Giant herds of bully mammoths and it
appears lIke it may have been warmer
than now during the ice age,
which is very odd.
There's some ice up there.
Is that what we're seeing?
Yeah,
there's some ice up there.
Sporadic glaciers,
but nothing like what we see in
northwestern europe over here.
This was called the pheno scandi and ice
sheet.
And the sheet over north America
actually consisted of two ice sheets,
the lauren laurentide,
which was centered over hudson bay,
and record the aaron,
which was centered over the canadian
rockies.
And in this particular slide you can see
a,
you can see here,
this was the core of the aaron over
here,
over the canadian rockies,
and this was the law,
the laurentide was much bigger c,
and then there was an area between the
two right here,
which has been theorized as a,
at one point,
having been a corridor called the
icefree corridor in migrants from
paleoindian.
Migrants from siberia would have come
across Alaska and down through this
corridor here to the lower United States
and ultimately down here to south
America.
And it was that group,
these groups of bands of paleo indian
hunters that according to the overkill
or blitzkrieg hypothesis wiped out the,
the,
the mega mammals as they,
as they passed by.
It's just.
Let's see.
Okay,
there we go.
Okay.
So here,
this will show,
uh,
the coastlines of the,
of the world during the,
uh,
during the ice age.
And uh,
let me just escape out of this so that
we can zoom in a little bit and look at
it closer.
Okay.
So here would be,
as we see now,
and
this is modern coastline,
this is modern coastlines.
And now I'm going to,
I'm going to jump to.
This is actually only 300 feet lower
than now and quite a bit different.
let's just look at the United States.
North America.
That's amazinG.
It was a lot more United States.
Yeah.
Now check this out.
Okay.
Now here,
here's north America city is now,
and you see up here,
this is what's called,
this is the bering strait right here in
between Alaska and siberia,
right during the ice age.
This whole area was exposed it because
of the lowered sea level.
And we'll go one slide further and you
will see.
Take a look.
Now,
watch what happens up there.
And Bahrain jia.
Boom.
Wow.
So it's all land.
It's all land and it's connecting north
America to siberia.
And that's all drowned.
Last didn't understand that.
See,
I always thought that the bering strait
was an ice mass that thought it was
during the ice age,
that there was some sort of us that it
was ice,
but it's not.
It's land.
wow.
and it's not glaciated.
And it was home to these extraordinary
herds of mega mammals that ranged over
these thousands and thousands of square
miles.
I mean the drowned areas bigger than
modern Alaska.
So how,
how long ago was this?
When this is,
you know,
right at the end,
up until the end of the ice age,
you know,
between like 14,
15,000
years ago,
14,
50,000
years ago.
Know glacIers in this area.
This is all just land and there's
animals living in it and people are
walking back and forth is.
I mean,
essentially it was a continent.
I mean it was connected.
There was all one continent.
It was all one.
It was all one continent.
Wow.
That's amazing.
And the coastlines of the world.
Look at Florida down here.
See,
it's douBle the width of the modern
peninsula.
Yeah,
it's enormous and it's so close to
Mexico too.
It's almost like a little boat ride.
Now,
here is Indonesia and you know,
we're,
we're stories,
which I don't know how credible they
are,
but you know,
there are stories like memoria and the
pacific and all of them.
again,
I don't know,
a credible.
Those are.
I think the atlanta story actually has a
little more credibility.
We talked about that last time somewhat,
but here's the modern and you can see
the light.
Blue is the,
is the coastal shelf area right now.
Let's go back drop.
We're going to drop sea level 300 feet
and then you'll see here the enormous
change.
Whoa.
So again,
enormous areas of land were drowned by
the rising sea levels.
Remember this now,
when we look at the rise of modern
cities and modern civilizations,
where did they first show up?
We're going to coast to coast,
right at the mouths of rivers,
on the coastlines,
and in during the ice age,
where would have been the most obvious?
Prime,
habitable real estate down close to sea
level,
right?
So if there were cities built,
you know,
if they were thriving communities during
the ice age,
there are now 400 feet under the water.
It's so amazing that all of these
stories of floods,
the epic of gilgamesh,
noah's ark.
Yeah.
They all have these stories seem to
really correlate with,
with all this data.
I mean,
they all seemed to coincide.
That's exactly the point.
It's so weird.
I,
you know,
most people would think about the story
of noah's ark.
Oh,
it's just crazy old horse shit,
but it's most likely this.
They're basing it on something that
happened very rapidly in their area.
Yeah.
Now,
of course we were most familiar with the
story of noah's ark,
you know,
because of the judeo christian
tradition.
But there are hundreds,
literally hundreds of stories from all
over the world that parallels the story
of noah.
One yard.
You kaylene thrusts the,
pitched them,
man knew that list goes on and on of
these culture heroes that somehow had
for knowledge of this impending
disaster.
And we're able To take steps to preserve
themselves,
their family,
some diverse cross section of,
of species.
Um,
which,
and they all have this similarity.
They all parallel now my way of looking
at it as this.
Okay,
we now know from the hard geological
record that massive floods have taken
place on the surface of the earth,
massive floods,
right beyond anything that we have even
imagined right up until a decade or few
decades ago.
They're real okay.
On the other hand,
we have stories and myths and legends
repeatedly.
It's probably the most ubiquitous of all
the stories that we've inherited from
the past is this story of this gigantic
world destroying flood that occurred
right now.
On one hand we have the geological hard
geological record,
which shows there were giant floods.
Then we have these epIc tales and myths
from all over the world about giant
floods.
Do we now dismissed those flood,
those,
those stories out of hand and say,
oh,
that's just superstitious preliterate,
you know,
pseudoscientific nonsense.
I think we'd be making a big mistake to
do that.
Now if we accept that those flood
stories and maybe they have been altered
through time and through the telling
represent something real.
What about the other other elements of
the story,
the fact that in so many cases there was
somebody that had for knowledge,
do we dismiss that out of hand as well,
you know,
or where does that come from?
That there was one group of people,
small group of people that saw this
thing coming and prepared for it and
others who basically paid no attention.
Maybe they would just preppers.
Maybe there's the prep for 10,000
years ago.
Preppers have 10,000
years on those tv shows that explains
it.
Right?
The one last slide quick here,
here's,
here's europe and look at the british
isles right now.
We'll drop sea level.
No british isles.
That's incredible.
See,
that's what I was saying earlier when we
started talking to the world of 15,000
years ago was so dramatically different
than our modern world that,
you know,
it's,
it's almost difficult to conceive until
you start looking at things like this.
and this is all during the ice age.
Yes.
And so the melting of the glaciers just
changed everything.
Every thought process while human beings
were absolutely alive.
So yeah,
absolutely,
absolutely no question.
The human human beings were alive.
Yes.
Okay,
so we'll start looking at some of these
pictures here.
This is from western Montana.
You know it says in genesis seven,
19,
the waters prevailed exceedingly upon
the earth and all the high hills
recovered.
We want you to take a look.
As you can see many mountains in western
United States.
If you know what you're looking at that
have this on them,
you know what those are,
those horizontal lines they look like,
like where the shore there shoreline
exactly their shorelines.
That's absolutely what they are.
Their shorelines reaching right up to
the very tops of the hills.
You see,
and basically what you had was you had
this enormous gush of water filling
these mountain valleys almost to the
mountain peaks and then draining away
and as it drained away,
it left the succession of shorelines
etched into the hillside and all along
the pathway of the floods,
we're going to see stuff like this.
This right?
This was our first stop with graham.
This is a lot to ral falls.
This is that basalt I was talking about.
Look at this stuff.
There's layers of this basalt or that's
you guys underneath it.
Um,
I don't think in despair.
I think I took this picture about 10
years ago,
but yeah,
I have pictures of me and graham under
there.
The,
you're so tiny.
That's so crazy.
It's so big right now.
Here's what you've got to picture joe
picture.
You've got this nice gentle valley with
a nice river,
very pastoral scene.
You know,
trees and stuff.
Probably mamasan herds of animals
grazing along the side of this peaceful
river with gentle chatt valley slopes.
Here comes this massive flood and we're
talking about perhaps a flood wave 800,
1000 feet hIgh coming through as it
comes through.
It's ripping up everything in its path
and it,
what it does is it now changes the
profile of his valley from this gentle
profile to downcutting 800,
a thousand,
1200 feet or more into the bedrock.
Right?
So now prior to the passage of this
giant flood,
you had streams and nice little rivers
flowing into the main river,
which in this case was the columbia.
What happens is after the passage of
this flood wave,
it sheared off the sides of the channel,
so the now rather than a gentle slope,
you've got sheer cliffs,
four,
five,
600 feet high.
These pre-flood streams and rivers come
up and are now waterfalls,
and that's what we're looking at right
here in this picture,
if that makes sense to you,
and and you notice how you've got this
undercutting here,
that undercutting only occurs when you
have enormous intense turbulence in the
water doIng this.
You see the water doing this will
undercut.
See this modern waterfall here had
nothing to do with the creation of this
cliff.
This cliff was cut again probably in a
matter of days to weeks by the passage
of these jargon floods,
and there's dozens of these waterfalls
that are left.
They're called and these are called
hanging valleys.
They can be produced by glaciers,
but they can also be produced by
enormous intense flood waves.
This is your typical,
not no appointment,
not typical.
This is called.
This is a bar.
I'm a gravel bar,
but in this case it's a boulder bar.
And if you've ever done any walking
along a river or a creek or along the
beach and you've seen ripples in the
sand and they're typically,
you know,
if you've got a water that's a foot or
two feet deep,
you don't have ripples that are maybe an
inch or two high.
What we're looking at here is a flood
bar that's three miles long.
It's up to 250 feet above the modern
river.
And the ripples that you can see here
are up to 50 feet in height and 350 feet
in wavelength.
This was produced again by gigantic
flood flows.
And if we look right over here,
that's a three story building you see
right there for scale.
Um,
wow.
So this,
this gives you an idea.
It's,
it's features like this that are just
unequivocal in terms of realizing that
this is,
this is not pseudoscience.
This really happened.
And this is,
there's this date back to a very
specific time.
Yes to this 13,000
year.
So everywhere you're seeing thIs,
you've seen a.
Geologically you've seen an ice core as
you're seeing it in fossils.
Yes.
Wow,
this is evidence of the big meltdown.
Has anybody ever tried to debate you on
this stuff?
Uh,
I would certainly welcome debate.
I don't claim to have the final,
final word on this,
but you know,
here's the thing.
I've,
I've interacted with a lot of geologists
that are studying this professional
geologists.
They're studying this.
what I can tell you is that in most
cases,
the geologists that are studying it,
it's not something,
it's basically something that you're
doing in your spare time.
Um,
most of them are engaged,
you know,
either you know,
in the,
uh,
in energy industry or working for
government for other purposes.
What you actually will see here though,
when you being to look at the,
the,
the trend in the evidence is that I
think that the geological community is
moving much closer to a scenario like
I'm describing.
And right now there's actually a
controversy because,
you know,
some of the older guard is wanting to
defend this idea of the old collapse.
This pro,
this giant lake draining out.
There are a group of canadian geologists
though,
who are,
who are challenging that under a
leadership of a man who may now be
retired named John Shaw,
who goes back to the 19 eighties and
began a reinterpretation of a,
of a very ubiquitous glacial feature
called [inaudible].
Um,
and,
and that we're,
I can show you some pictures of him here
after a bit there.
They're very interesting.
um,
they look like inverted bolt holes and
it was assumed and are always associated
with the locations of the glaciers and
the ice sheets.
So it was therefore assume that they
were somehow created by the glaciers
themselves,
but glaciers tend to grind things that
they're moving over in level things off
and scratch them and leave striations.
And all of this abrasion,
these drum ones are smooth,
streamlined features.
What shaw first proposed back in the
late eighties was that they had actually
been produced by water flowing massive
amounts of water flowing under the
glaciers.
And there's a very similar,
the,
the critics said,
well,
where does this water come from?
And he said,
well,
I don'T know.
It must have been enormous.
SubglacIal lake subglacial reservoirs.
The critics said,
well,
there's no way that our reservoir is
huge as your floods would require,
could have existed under the ice.
Therefore your subglacial floods didn't
exist and that was the.
To me,
the fatal weakness in his theory was to
explain where the water came from,
but I think now we can't explain where
it came from and you believe it's an
asteroid impact again,
by default I,
there's,
we have,
we look at all the possible,
the cross section of possible
explanations within the realm of nature.
We can go through and we can eliminate
this one,
and what we're left with is one that of
itself would be fully capable of doing
it fully capable and make sense that it
would happen instantaneous.
That would make sense.
It would happen instantaneously.
Other sort of thing that would.
Yes.
So is there an impact crater that
corresponds to this timeline or.
That's what I'm working on trying to
find it.
Yeah,
and I think I've.
I think I've got a pretty good idea,
but it's going to take some field
research and next summer I'm planning to
do some some more field research.
Is there an idea where it hit a.
Yeah,
I have several ideas.
We don't want to talk about it when
it's.
When it's time to reveal it.
Okay.
Let's do it here.
Oh,
I'd love that.
I would love that.
Well,
you,
you've shown several impact craters.
You showed a bunch last time you were
here,
the one in Australia that was,
I believe you said 500 years ago.
Yeah,
and of course everybody medically,
it hasn't been proven yet because again,
some of these more recent craters of the
last 10,000
years,
some of these that have been
hypothesized are actually on the bottom
of the ocean.
The trader that I think we talked about
on the bottom of the indian ocean,
it's under two miles of seawater,
so until we can actually get back there
in and do more in depth sampling in
examination,
it'll be impossible to prove it,
but I think that the,
the evidence is stronGly supportive of
that possibility that maybe 5,000
years ago there was a significant impact
into the indian ocean that could have
caused enormous tsunami waves.
Now,
I actually posted one of the,
uh,
somebody called into queStion some of
the things I had said in the last
interview about tsunamis.
And at that the things I was saying
weren't really tsunami.
So I actually wrote an elaborate
response to that which is posted on the
sacred geometry website where I've gone
into great detail.
I'm showing that the evidence really in
the end I think does support the idea
that there had been enormous tsunamis,
possibly hundreds of feet high,
sweeping over the coastlines of the
indian ocean probably around 5,000
years ago.
That could have been the origin of some
of the flood myths
and your timeline where this mass
extinction event occurred,
where the massive warming occurred.
all of that also coincides with the
discovery of this nuclear glass all over
asian europe,
which is somewhere in the when they do
the core samples of around the same
area,
right around $12,000
years ago.
Yes.
We can see here.
We'll go through a second.
This is some of the research you can
see.
This is.
This is very typical,
the mysterious onset of the younger
dryas.
Now this is.
This has been the kind of the consensus
view is that,
okay,
we don't have an explanation.
The younger dryas remembers.
That's an interval between those two
spikes,
right where you had the warming than the
snap back to glacial cold and in the
warming again,
so that interval in between is the
younger dryas.
So here they're saying the mysterious
onset of the younger dryas,
the 1300 year long younger dryas cold
reversal,
and you notice the date's twelve
thousand nine hundred and eleven
thousand six hundred.
That means calendar years before
present.
So what they've done is they've
calibrated this from radio carbon dating
too,
which is not necessarily going to be the
same as the actual calendar years.
So those dates are very interesting.
Um,
11,000,
600 years ago,
you may recall from our last interview,
is the date given by plato for the
subsidence of atlantis.
Eleven thOusand.
I mean,
he says that atlanta subsided in.
You can.
Anybody can read this if they want to
pick up timaeus and critias the two
dialogues that he describes atlantis and
he gives that date 9,000
years before the
exile of long in Egypt,
which took place in 600 bc roughly.
So six huNdred bc in rough roughly is
2,600
years ago.
Add that to the 9,000
years and years.
Your $11,600.
So now what has happened is 2,500
years ago,
plato gave a date,
which would seem to suggest that
something,
some something.
A man's happened in the atlantic ocean
and you had an island complex that sank
perhaps from rapid sea level rise.
Now 2,500
years later.
Here's modern science coming up with the
exact date showing,
hey,
there was a massive meltwater pulse into
the ocean at that date.
Now at this point,
nobody within mainstream science is
going,
oh,
well,
see he doesn't mention here.
Oh,
that's the date given by plato.
They don't say that,
but it's.
It is the case.
That's incredible.
That's so amazing.
Now,
plato,
that he was told that it was all through
stories.
It was.
Yeah,
it was handed down soul on,
handed down.
Let's see if I can remember this.
Through deprived esther pitus to
courteous.
The elder critias,
the elder to courteous.
The younger then critias the younger,
I guess to socrates actually at the
forum we're plato would have heard it
would have been the socratic forum where
it was told,
so I think there was like three
generations between salon in plato,
the wise men of the time or the people
that were in charge of disseminating
knowledge.
Back then it was such a critical job.
Critical job.
Yes,
no internet,
no books and,
and,
and the,
the whole thing was,
was that the whole emphasis was on
transmit.
The oral transmission had to take place
without not one iota of change.
It had to be transmitted from mouth to
ear,
unbroken without change,
without alteration,
which has always been the issue with
human beings.
Hence that telephone game.
You tell someone something,
they tell you something,
but if you start out in,
you know it's going to be the same with
native americans and the native american
storytellers have to go through a very
long arduous term of initiation to show
that when they tell the story,
it's going to be exactly like they heard
it.
That's one of the basis of modern
freemasonry too.
We need to get that with today's modern
gossip.
Yeah,
we need to nail that,
but let's just run through a quick
succession here.
If some of the most recent research
shock synthesized hexagonal diamonds in
younger dryas boundary sediments,
whoa,
now these shocks synthesized hexagonal
diamonds only occur.
There's no natural known natural process
that will produce them except for the
intense heat and pressures of a cosmic
impact.
Whoa.
Okay.
And what year was this study?
Oh,
this has been very recent.
This is probably within the last 10
years.
there was some since 2007.
This is probably around 2011.
There was something that was released
very recently about micro diamonds and
micro diamonds correspond summer.
Yeah,
and that also was the same timeline,
so it's just like the evidence keeps
accumulating in this time period that
something hit us.
The micro diamonds,
the nuclear glass spikes in warming.
That's observable on the ice core
correlates that mass extinction events
of all these animals.
This is an event.
Well,
I.
This is crazy that you're.
You're the guy talking about this event.
I mean this is really nuts,
but not anything taken away from you,
but there's so few people beating this
drum that there's so much information.
We're talking about hard data.
You've shown on this show three,
four different examples of hard data
that points to this event.
Well see,
here's the thing.
Modern science does tend to get over
specialized and so what happens is the
guy looking at extinctions might not be
looking at,
you know,
glacial melting.
The guy who is looking at glacial
melting isn't,
the geologist is not looking at what's
going on in the sky,
they're not looking at,
you know,
traditions from thousands of years ago.
So what it does is because of the power
of this specialization,
specialization is extremely powerful,
but he's shortcoming is that it's easy
to miss the big picture.
What that does is opens the door for
generalists.
Guys who are just people who are just
say guys,
men or women,
anybody who's curious about this stuff,
to look into it and try to see the big
picture.
Why am I bringing this?
Well it's becAuse for 40 years I've been
obsessed with this stuff and you know,
I read two or three scientific articles
every single day and have done so for 40
years plus.
So that adds up after awhile and I don't
just read them.
I study,
I might take notes,
you know,
two or three every single day.
So you figure what is that?
That's 2000 a year.
You go back 40 years.
That's means I probably read something
on the order of 40,000
scientific articles from anthropology,
geology when I studied geology and
astronomy in college,
so I have some academic background in
that,
but,
but you know,
basically what I have done is tried to
piece together the big picture because
early on I saw nobody's doing that.
Nobody's doing it really,
and some of the guys that are out there
doing it are not doing it with academic
rigor,
you know,
they're bringing in all kinds of weird
stuff which makes it easy for the
critics to attack them and dismiss them
as fringe science.
The throne,
some wound to the mix.
They're throwing some wound to the mix.
In fact,
one of the,
the,
the rational wiki entry on me says
something about randall carlson and he
is woo and that's all it says.
You know?
So I took that.
And so people love to be able to dismiss
anything that's not mainstream.
Right?
It's outside.
Yeah.
Because there's this cult of authority,
you know,
that's why you're here.
Somebody says,
well,
what is a real scientists say about
this?
What is a real scientists say about this
flood into my current role,
which real scientists,
you know,
vic baker,
richard,
wait,
uh,
you know,
roy breckinridge,
I've,
I've read or talk to every,
almost every scientist that's done work
on the missoula flood,
you know,
so I know what they're saying and what
they're thinking,
you know,
and what they've written it.
So,
so,
you know,
when you say,
well,
what are the real scientists say?
Well,
okay,
let's get a little more specific.
Who are you talking about?
Because there are different points of
view,
you know,
are you talking about John Shaw idea?
Are you talking about,
you know,
victor bakers ideas or,
or,
or any of the others?
Well,
you know,
and that's the thing,
they say that because they don't really
know they've got this idea in your mind
that there's this authority that's got
it all explained,
which makes it easy,
right?
Because if somebody got it explained,
then we don't need to concern ourselves
with it or think about it.
Right?
so what I say is,
okay,
forget about who says what.
Let's just look at the facts that the
facts dictate to us what the meaning of
all of this is,
you know,
and let's look at all points of view
because that's what I try to do.
You know,
I've got in my,
in my archives here,
I've got,
you know,
not only the research that supports the
idea of a,
of a cosmic impact back during the
younger dryas,
but to criticisms of it as well,
you know,
and I go,
okay,
how can we explain those criticisms and
into give and take of science.
That's part of the process,
you know,
that's how it evolves because somebody
puts out a new idea,
you're supposed to attack it,
you know,
and then if it withstands the assault,
the onslaught that shows that it's a
credible idea,
you know,
it's like a last man standing sort of
thing.
And I think that the cosmic impact
really is going to end up being the last
man standing.
Well,
it seems like there's so much evidence
that you're,
you're,
you're bringing up that's so hard.
You know the,
this,
the,
how do you say that word?
Hca.
Contract.
Contract like mineral from black,
matte,
I mean all the,
the,
the various things,
the micro diamonds,
the nuclear glass,
the mass extinction events,
the evidence of uh,
the loading,
warming,
the flooding,
the c level,
raw,
all of it.
All,
all this burn area.
Yeah.
And this,
this is basically st conrad chondrites
are a type of media,
right?
So this is saying,
right,
like material,
in other words,
material that would have had its origin
in space from the black man.
Now this black man is really
interesting.
I'm going to show you a couple of slides
of it because this black matte layer,
it's black.
The reason it's black is because it's so
loaded with what is the result of fire,
right?
So let's,
let's go through here.
This discovery of a nano diamond rich
layer and the greenland ice sheet.
So nobody had looked,
but when these guys,
richard firestone and James West and
james candidate,
these other scientists
that are working on this younger dryas
impact hypothesis said to their
colleagues,
check out the younger dryas boundary
layer 12,000,
900 years ago and see if there's
anything that shows up there.
They did,
and what do you suppose they found here
in his right here?
A nano diamond rich layer.
So there it is showing up in the ice
sheets.
Here's new evidence from a black math
site into northern andy's supporting a
cosmic impact.
Twelve thousand,
800 years ago,
a very high temperature impact melt
products as evidence for cosmic airburst
impacts 12,900.
So they,
you know,
they haven't,
they're getting closer and closer to
refining the date,
but it's coming in 12,800
to 12,900
years ago.
Um,
wildlife,
wildfire and abrupt ecosystem disruption
on california's northern channel islands
at the aloe rod.
Younger dryas boundary at basically
12,900.
Twelve point nine k means 12,000,
900 years ago.
It was the universal means a thousand.
It's crazy.
It's all the same.
Everything keeps coming back the same
date.
Yeah.
Nano diamond rich layer across three
continents consistent with major cosmic
impact at 12,800
calendar years before present.
Evidence from central Mexico supporting
the younger dryas,
extraterrestrial impact hypothesis,
evidence from northwestern venezuelan,
andy's for extraterrestrial impact,
the black mat,
enigma evidence for deposition of 10
million.
Tons of impact spiros across four
continents.
Twelve thousand,
800 years ago.
See,
it's coming in,
man.
It's coming in and abundance and what's
gratifying to me as I theorized this 25
years ago.
Wow.
And it to see now the hard evidence
coming in supporting a scenario I had
pieced together from all of these
different realms of knowledge is very
gratifying to me.
What was the seed in your mind that led
you to be obsessed,
for lack of a better word,
with this anomaly thing?
Lack of a better word.
I think it's pretty accurate,
right?
With this subject.
Okay.
I guess iT's time to come clean.
I was on mushrooms on top of a mountain.
Well,
no,
you're actually pretty close.
Okay.
Nineteen 69.
That's a good year.
Mushrooms.
Well,
wasn't mushrooms but it was something in
the family.
Okay.
I'm going to a rock concert.
Right?
And the beautiful summer day,
early summer 12.
Twelve thousand 900 years ago.
No,
19,
69,
right.
Okay.
So it's.
It's on a field next to a little airport
in just out southwest of the twin
cities,
Minnesota,
which was near where I grew up in the
Minnesota river.
Flows through there,
right?
Minnesota river flows into the
Mississippi.
I think I'll have some slides coming up
here.
I can maybe even show you.
Okay.
So what we have here is that in the
middle of this thing,
between bands or whatever,
I wandered off from the main area where
the,
where the crowd was gathered to listen
to the music and I walked over to these
200 foot high bluffs overlooking the
valley of the missing of the Minnesota
river.
Now the Minnesota river currently flows
in a little channel at the bottom of
this valley and I'm standing up on this
hill and I'm looking down at this
Minnesota river,
you know,
hundreds of feet below me in this
channel and three miles,
four miles across.
I see another set of bluffs matching the
ones that I'm standing on.
And I had this.
All I can say is this was kind of a
revelation that I'm looking down here at
this little river flowing into a channel
and then I'm seeing just a gigantic
version of that same channel,
but it's three and four miles wide and I
just looked at that and it was almost as
if for a short period of time I got
transplanted out of time or something.
I don't know how to explain it.
You can see this raging river had this
sense that this whole thing was a
gigantic river.
At one time.
I came away from that with this idea
planted in the back of my brain and it
bugged me for years after that.
Right,
and it was maybe five,
six years.
This is now into the seventies.
There was not a whole lot on
catastrophism available in the
seventies.
There was,
you know,
a manual makowski,
one of the forerunners,
but you know,
he,
he came up with some really wild ideas
that made it very easy for mainstream
science to dismiss him,
but he came up with some really solid
ideas to his book.
Earth and upheaval basically was just a
documentation of all of this geological
evidence for great catastrophes in the
history of the earth.
I think he misinterpreted the cause of
those catastrophes.
But nonetheless,
when you look at the criticisms you've
heard of the manual vela kosky,
right?
Fellow cops think I've heard it from
you.
Okay.
Well,
he was famous bestselling author,
one of the big best selling authors of
the 19 fifties,
you know,
maybe in a sense a forerunner of,
in fact,
graham hancock has been compared to vela
koskie now.
And then I've actually seen some of some
of that.
Um,
although vela [inaudible] work I don't
think was anywhere near as credible as
graham's.
Graham is very,
very assiduous in his,
his referencing in his detailing.
And so vela kosky went way off into this
really weird astrophysics to explain
his,
his theories of geological catastrophe,
which again allowed the critics to
basically dismiss everything he had done
so.
But his book,
earth and upheaval,
I think has upheld the test of time.
We were basically in the 19 fifties.
He was accumulating all of this evidence
suggesting that there had been
catastrophes in earth history and what
was it,
like I said,
a best seller,
but the mainstream scientific community
was very dismissive of it.
Okay.
And then after that you had a book
called,
uh,
by charles hapgood called the path of
the pole.
I think it came out in [inaudible] 76
and he,
he and near theorized that there had
been a sudden shift that had brought
about the quick freezing of the mammoths
and the end of the ice age and so forth.
Um,
so I was familiar with that stuff and I
would,
I would read that stuff just out of
curiosity,
you know,
um,
because that was some of the stuff that
was out there.
And,
and um,
you know,
somebody would say,
hey,
did you read the lukowski?
And so as I was reading this stuff,
I would keep thinking back to this image
I'd had of this,
you know.
And then in early eighties I was talking
to somebody,
I actually gave one of my very early
lectures on this stuff and there was
somebody who had a degree in geology who
stood up and he said,
no,
that,
that valley that you're talking about,
which created over millions of years.
I said,
I don't think so.
And we kind of got into it a little bit
in,
but what that did was it kind of pissed
me off.
And I said,
okay,
I'm going to research this thoroughly.
And I did.
I thoroughly researched it.
I went and I found every single thing
that had been written on it and
discovered that there's actually
mainstream geologists that have said,
yeah,
that river channel,
that giant river channel was actually
created by a huge meltwater flood.
And they estimated that it's volume.
They called it river warren.
They estimated it as volume,
might've been 4,000
times greater than the modern Minnesota
river that's flowing in there.
So I felt very vindicated from that.
And this was by the early eighties.
So that was like one of the key things.
There was other things,
you know,
I um,
I spent the summer of 1970 mostly
sitting on a mountain top in Colorado,
you know,
in a hut that I had built studying and
reading stuff and,
and,
and traveling.
I knoW this was back in the days when
you could hitchhike and travel all over
and I think at one point I was with a
buddy and we were in his old camper van
and other times I would teach anchor,
but I spent the whole summer traveling
around the western states.
And the thing I came away from that
summer with the.
I'd traveled the first time I had
traveled down to columbia gorge.
And as I did,
I had this overwhelming sense that there
was something in the landscape that I
was,
that was,
that was waiting to be revealed.
I would look at these features in the
columbia records when I showed you that
huge waterfall with the basalt over and
that's in the columbia gorge.
So that was the area I had traveled
through in 1970.
And I came away with that with this
sense,
that point or something that,
that landscape is trying to tell me.
And so it goes back to that and I just,
you know,
I got very in this stuff
because I'm interested a in science and
I love the outdoors.
So I love a good mystery,
you know,
and I love,
ancient traditions were.
So all this sort of came together over a
period of a couple of decades.
Um,
so I began really,
I would say obsessive lee really going
into this in the early eighties,
you know,
where it went from,
just more or less casual reading into,
you know,
spending hours in university libraries
for digging up these things.
Going back to the ninth,
going back to the early geologists to
see what were they saying,
why did they believe that the history of
the earth had been catastrophic,
you know,
and um,
and it just accelerated.
It doesn't seem like a ridiculous idea
at all.
When you consider what we see on the
moon and the moon is so fascinating
because we can look right at it.
There's no oceans,
there's no forests.
We can see the evidence of impacts all
over it just completely covered,
completely covered with our minds living
in this very small window of life,
you know,
if we're lucky,
we get 100 years and then of course we
have the history which goes back to
about seven plus thousand years.
This is not enough to really to
represent what we're looking at.
When we look at the moon,
we look at the moon that's covered with
craters.
We're looking at potentially billions of
years of impacts.
Yes.
And,
and the assumption that those impacts
ceased hundreds of millions or billions
of years ago is clearly not correct.
Well,
there's no evidence that seized or why
it would cease.
When we look at how many we known near
earth objects are floating around.
Oh,
in the last few years there's been
dozens of close flybys.
That was one the other day that had a
fucking moon.
Yes.
So something that flew by that have its
own moon.
Yeah.
That's wild.
And so think about this,
joe.
Here's what's happening.
We've got geologists who are looking at
the crust of the earth in discovering
that,
yeah,
if we strip away the biosphere in the
oceans and an account for plate
tectonics,
the earth is going to look like the
moon.
Right?
Are noW hundreds of identified craters,
right?
At the same time,
astronomers are looking out into the
near space near the near earth
neighborhood of space and discovering,
wait a second,
we assumed that we were pretty much
isolated.
There was nothing else going on.
We're now realizing that near or spaces
densely populated,
the inner solar system is densely
populated with cosmic debris and this
stuff is western bias all the time and
it's now at the same time.
You've got paleontologists who are
looking at the record of life and
realizing that the record of life is not
a smooth curve.
It seesawed,
you know,
life proliferates and then suddenly bam.
It's like the hammer comes down and you
have these mass extinction events,
so this is our time right now,
but it could very easily end.
There could be some new bug like
creature that takes over and become
super smart a billion years from now.
To me,
it all comes down to this.
This to me is like,
okay,
human species on planet earth,
it's time for you to grow up and start
paying attention to the bigger picture
because whether you like it or not,
you're a part of the bigger picture.
And if we,
if we finally accept the fact that maybe
our predecessors have undergone in a
sense,
cultural mass extinctions,
you know,
it suddenly implies that we can't take
our own unending future for granted that
we have.
We have to incorporate this bigger
picture into our thinking.
and you know,
the evidence has continues to yes.
Like here,
this was just from 2011 multiple lines
of evidence for possible human
population decline.
Settlement reorganization during the
early,
younger dryas into three years,
four years since this was published.
More evidence has emerged that yes,
the,
the events that caused the mass
extinction of half the great mega
mammals on earth did not leave the rest
of the mammals the rest of the animals
unscathed,
including humans.
And there is now emerging evidence,
hard scientific evidence that the human
population crashed during the younger
dryas.
So this would completely coincide with
graham hancock's ideas about the sphinx.
Sphinx.
Absolutely showing very clear,
according to robert schoch,
boston university geologists,
John Anthony West,
that there is clear evidence of water
erosion on the sphinx,
which would indicate thousands of years
of rainfall where there hasn't been
rainfall in the nile valley since,
I believe it was 9,000
bc.
So that's 11,000
years ago.
It's all the same stuff.
God,
this is crazy.
Yeah,
we're,
we're on the verge of a major paradIgm
shift and where it's going to go remains
to be seen.
We live in a shooting gallery.
We live.
We listened.
it's not an exaggeration to say that we
are sitting ducks in a cosmic shooting.
Gail.
Exactly.
But the point is,
here's the point,
is the only thing that's see,
it's like,
what was it in the.
In the book of matthew,
there's an interesting quote,
and I'm not,
I'm not not thumping the bible here,
but the bible is full of just like all
the traditions of ages are gone.
The bible is full of some very powerful,
interesting stuff.
There's a part in here and we're one of
the disciples asked jesus about when are
we going to know about the end of days?
And he says,
well,
as it was in the days of noah,
when the people were eating and drinking
and marrying and giving in marriage.
So will it be again in the days,
the end of days when the flood comes,
when the people were eating and
drinking,
marrying and giving in marriage until
the flood came and swept them away.
So will it be again at the end of days?
So what that seems to indicate to me is
that we just get comfortable and relaxed
and do well.
And when we do well,
that's when you get hit.
But it's not saying that the everyday
stuff,
the stuff of everyday life,
there's anything wrong.
It's not saying that,
it's just saying if we get so
preoccupied with the minutia and the
trivia of everyday life to the exclusion
of the bigger picture,
that's when we open ourselves up with
has been.
I've had these weird coNversations with
people about asteroidal impacts over the
years because I've.
Before I even met you,
I've been obsessed with this stuff.
not nearly as much as when I met you in
atlanta and we started talking then I
got really into it.
but would they would talk about the
asteroids that killed the dinosaur.
Oh,
today we'd be able to stop that.
And I'm like,
okay,
really?
Is that true?
And then I started looking into it.
Well,
what has been done is nothing.
Some fucking theories.
See here,
here's the thing.
Potentially yes we could.
Someday we could do it.
And,
and really,
you know,
within,
within a decade or two.
Yes we could.
We could do that right now potentially.
But see what happened on February 15th
of 2014 when that little meatier came in
and exploded over chelyabinsk siberia
injured 1500 people now in damaged
thousands of buildings.
That was a wake up call,
right?
That was a little suspect.
it was a little speck.
Now here's the thing,
if he had been a little bigger,
a little dancer,
if it's an angle of approach,
had been a little steeper.
If it's velocity had been a little bit
greater,
we might've been looking at thousands of
deaths rather than just injuries and
tunguska,
as you said,
only 150 foot wide.
Only 150 foot wide objeCt.
Right,
right.
So that's very,
very small in the cosmic sense.
This room.
Yeah.
Well it's the building from here to the
front door,
you knoW what I mean?
That's not that big.
It's not that big.
Once you've got though is velocity and
you think like,
you know,
think of a say a 38 slug.
It's not big.
If I was to throw it at you,
even as hard as I could,
it might sting a little bit,
but it wouldn't do any damage,
but if it came out of a gun with a
muzzle velocity of a thousand feet per
second,
think about that little thing and what
the damage it would do to you and see.
That's the thing about an asteroid or
meteorite or a comet coming in.
It's moving really,
really fast.
You know,
so that's why,
like I said,
it packs such a powerful kinetic punch
when it hits and some of them are even
made of iron.
Some of them are made of iron and so.
So if,
if there's,
if there's a moral dollar this,
it's simply this look,
we are the one species that could
prevent the type of mass
extinctions that have dominated the
biosphere of this planet for a couple of
hundred million years.
Or we could keep putting our resources
to fracking.
Yeah.
Well,
I still haven't made up my mind about
fracking yet,
but I do believe that what we need to do
is be thinking of,
if we're going to extract the resources
of this planet,
let's do so in such a way that what
we're doing is implementing the
transcendence of human culture into the
cosmos itself,
because I ultimately believe that is the
destiny of terrestrial life is the
terrestrial life wants to become cosmic.
It knows on some level that as long as
life,
it's confined to the surface of a
planet.
It's vulnerable.
Right?
And,
and you know,
without getting into all of this,
there's,
there's growing evidence that life
originally came to this planet from
space,
right?
Was seated here probably through comets
that carry organic material.
All been.
Spare me her hand sperm.
Yeah,
exactly.
So here's the thing,
if you're an environmentalist and
rightfully critical of some of the
things that humans are doing to disrupt
the environment you got to the place in
context,
the fact that nature itself has done
things to the environment so that so far
exceed anything we have done yet what I
showed you with that slide,
showing the ice sheets over candidate.
Think about this.
Suppose some logging company got a
contract from the government,
us and canadian governments to clear cut
every forest from like the 47th parallel
up to the arctic circle from the
atlantic to the pacific.
We're going to cut every single tree
from the northern United States up to
the tree line in,
in northern Canada.
We're going to cut billions of trees,
billions of board feet.
we're going to clear cut every single
tree.
We would rightfully be up in arms and
say,
no,
you're not going to do that.
Right?
well,
what do you think that ice did?
It wiped out.
You know,
there's evidence now that 35 and 40,000
years ago,
there were forests growing up there,
right?
A few thousand years later,
the ice has bulldozed everything.
There's no forest growing under two
miles of ice,
right?
Imagine if we said,
well,
we're going to just decimate the shallow
marine ecology.
We're going to go in there and we're
going to just wiPe out the coral reefs
were going to overfish them till there's
no nothing,
nothing left of the shallow marine
ecology.
Ecology is less than 400 feet below sea
level.
What do you think are dropping 400 feet,
400 feet in the c level did to the
shallow marine ecologies to the coral
reefs that were growing there.
You see,
that's where I'm just saying it's not to
justify that we can ransacked nature
willy nilly,
but it's to say we have to have a
realistic context for thinking about
this and bear in mind that the
environmental movement was born during
an era of total
gradual listic dominance in the fifties
and sixties.
If you go back down again,
only the fringe,
the,
you know,
the fringe science people like vela
kowski and others were talking about
catastrophes.
The assumption was is that all global
change occurred one grain of sand or one
drop of water at a time,
right?
Well,
we've come a hundred 80 degrees from
that model of earth history,
but our thinking has not really evolved
to,
to incorporate such a dynamic planet.
You knoW,
at this point.
Now see,
so when the environmental movement was
born,
it was easy to think that if,
if all change,
it had happened at this imperceptibly
slow rate.
Obviously didn't humans have accelerated
that pace of change and humans are now
contributing to know more global change
than,
than we've seen in millions of years.
If that uniformitarian undergraduate
holistic model was correct,
but it's not.
And I'm afraid that thEre's a large
faction of the environmental movement
that's still locked into that thinking
of a gradual evolution of the planet.
One grain of water,
one drop of water,
one grain of sand at a time,
and that it has not suffered any kind of
disruption until we bad humans came
along and started,
you know,
with our factories and our oil wells and
our movies and everything else.
But you know,
clearly we have to come to terms with
the fact that we live on one hell of a
dynamic planet in one hell of a dynamic
solar system was a hell of a dying
without jupiter.
Right.
We'd be fucked a long time.
We would be.
Somebody said they wanted to hear me say
the word fuck at least once.
So I'll throw out.
Go ahead and throw it.
Yeah,
we would be fucked.
Jupiter is the big,
kind of like the bouncer for all the
bigger asteroids that get sucked into
jupiter can play a dual role.
See jupiter connect as a as.
Yeah,
the bouncer that it kicks a lot of those
guys back out,
back out into the kuyper disk or
wherever they came from or from.
But it can also hurdle stuff in towards
us.
It can do either one.
Sacred geometry is a subject that I
wanted to talk to you about because we.
We could go on about cataclysmic impacts
forever,
but it's one of the things that you
mentioned at the end of our last podcast
that you wanted to talk about on this
one and it's the name of your
organization.
Sacred geometry.
Well,
it's the name of the website.
Yeah.
I could find some stuff here to show you
about that.
And,
and it dovetails because bayer,
remember we're talking here a lot about
geology,
geometry,
right?
They both are sciences that have evolved
out of the study of the earth.
And uh,
you know,
one of the things that I've done is,
is in geology.
We have this thing called scale and
variance,
which is that if you're looking a
geological picture,
you're always gonna.
See somebody you're going to see like a
rock pick set in the picture,
you're going to see a person standing
there because oftentimes you don't have
a sense of the scale of what you're
looking at.
Right?
If,
and in geometry we have the same
phenomena.
It's also kind of the modern term for it
is fractal association where the part
looks,
the smaller part looks like the bigger
whole.
And that's one of the basic working
ideas of sacred geometry and it's the
same idea of what I was describing
standing there looking into the
Minnesota river valley.
This was an example of scale in variance
that you had the same,
that the big channel was just a much,
much larger version of this small
channel.
And if you didn't have a scale of
reference,
you couldn't tell really what you're
looking at,
how,
how big or how small it is.
See.
So in the study of sacred geometry,
one of the fundamental ideas is this
idea of scale and variance.
So when I first was interested in
geometry,
because geometry I think is one of the
keys to decipher in many of the ancient
traditions.
LIke you know,
I became a.
Somebody wanted me to talk about
freemasonry and I can talk about that up
to a certain extent.
You know,
one of the things that I learned as soon
as I actually,
I think I learned it before I was
actually initiated into the masonic
fraternity in 1978 was that at the core
of all of the masonic symbolism was
geometry.
If you wanted to understand the message
of the great cathedrals,
you had to have geometry.
If you wanted to understand the,
the,
this amazing plethora of symbolism that
has of which masons are the custodians.
You had to study geometry and
secondarily you had to study astronomy,
so that sort of confirmed some of the
ideas I had already been thinking at the
time that I went in in the,
in the late seventies.
Freemasonry is full of symbolism.
Why did you join the freemasons?
Well know,
because for one thing,
I've always loved you.
I come from a family of builders.
I build things for a living.
That's what I do.
I design things and build things for a
living.
That's what I.
How I make my money.
So I was always interested in the built
environment and somewhere along the line
I just began to realize that there was a
whole lot more to the built environment
of ancient times that in modern times
you look at architecture in that
architecture is not necessarily
symbolical except on a very abstract
sense.
I became aware of the fact that the
ancient architecture,
the ancient structures,
whether it's the pyramids of giza or
stonehenge or angkor wat,
are the mayan temples.
There are all profoundly symbolic.
They're not just built because,
hey,
it looks good.
No,
it's,
they convey information.
um,
you know,
cathedrals.
It was victor hugo who,
who referred to some of the great
cathedrals as being literal textbooks in
stone and that's what they are.
Sharp cathedral,
beautiful example of a textbook and
stone.
And,
and uh,
I have,
I don't know if you've ever been to any
of the cathedral that that's something
you need to put on your bucket list.
Joe.
I'm planning on going to europe this
summer,
so when I do on a vacation instead of
working.
Yeah,
that's.
make it a research vacation.
It will make a lot more interesting.
And maria,
go have kids.
It's tough to do a lot of research.
We've got little kids get bored real
easy,
but I'm going to check some shit out.
Checks and shit out,
you know,
and I can send you some places that I
don't know about your kids,
but I could easily have been eight years
old and been totally blown away by.
Well,
one of the things about the freemasons,
the idea of the free masons is that it's
a secret society and this a secret,
you know,
and people associated with the
illuminati and the people that control
the world and don't.
I wish.
But no,
I think I would love to be the dick,
dick supreme dictator of the world.
Really.
Why would you do differently?
Differently?
We could get into.
That's going to be,
yeah,
that's a five hour body,
but that's a different podcast.
But the.
But when you say like I'm a mason,
people would automatically,
you know,
especially ignorant people would
automatically assume that you're a part
of some sort of society that's
victimizing the general population and
you're involved with the people that put
the eyeball on top of the pyramid that's
on the dollar bill and your,
you know,
I don't even know where to start with
some of that.
Are there secrets in the freemasons
where you're not allowed to talk about
it?
Well,
bear in mind now secrets in in the
middle ages,
there were trade secrets and building
secrets.
Clearly,
you know,
and when you went through the process of
initiation,
you learned about these secrets,
right?
But it's not that really that different.
The idea than say modern commercial or
industrial secrets,
you know,
coke has,
it keeps it formula secret.
Right?
Right.
And has done so for 100 years.
But the thing was is you got to realize
that freemasonry became an outlawed
organization right during the middle
ages when the church was persecuting
anybody who was branded a heretic,
which could have meant anything that
they wanted to be free.
Masonry had to go underground.
And that's the primary reason for the
secrecy is because it was a survival
strategy and it only reemerged in nearly
1700 with the consolidation of four
lodges in britain to become the modern
institution freemason.
And you know,
to anybody who comes up with that,
I would just challenge him,
show me the hard evidence,
show me that,
you know,
I like to say that.
Well,
yeah,
I'll admit,
you know,
14 of the american presidents have been
free masons,
but 22 of them were episcopalians.
So clearly that implies me that it's the
episcopalians
who are the puppet masters ruling the
world,
right?
If you want to make that argument,
well why were they freemasons?
Like,
what's the benefits of being a
freemason?
Well,
for one thing,
what you're doing is you're aligning
yourself with probably the oldest
institution.
It still exists on the planet that goes
back.
Now we can historically trace it back to
the middle ages.
But if you go back further than that
wild,
the historical continuity breaks down.
We can go back and we can talk about the
coma.
Chines and Italy.
We can talk about the martin lists,
we can talk about the,
um,
the myth reyes tradition.
we can talk about the mysteries of
Egypt.
Uh,
we can talk about the,
the zoroastrian tradition.
Um,
the list goes on,
the loc and mysteries.
And what we see is a structure of
initiation,
it's virtually identical in all these
cases to what modern freemasonry is.
And I'm with modern freemasonry
basically,
you know,
you have a whole cross section of
individuals that join who,
who a lot of them joined simply because,
hey,
my dad was a freemason,
or my uncle,
it was a family tradition.
So that's why I joined.
Others joined because free masons raised
every year,
raised millions of dollars for charity,
mostly for children's,
a charitable causes,
you know,
they run the scottish rite hospital for
crippled children.
They run I hospitals and you know,
children that need medical care,
they can go to these hospitals and not
have to pay anything.
So they're fraternal organization or one
of the largest charitable organizations
on the planet in terms of the money that
they raised.
You know,
again,
jesus said by their,
by their works,
you shall know them.
You know,
um,
you know,
you can twist that around,
perversely,
twist that around and say that some kind
of nefarious strategy to,
you know,
whatever,
get control.
The other side of the equation is that
they're also custodians of this body of
ancient symbolism were all of these
things that we have been talking about
basically are encoded.
Um,
and,
and I could pull up some interesting
stuff here.
Did you know that you could look at to
see what we're actually talking about
there?
But,
but yeah,
they have this amazing body of
symbolism.
Let me,
let me pull it.
Here's how big an example of a masonic
apron.
Okay,
let's take a look at this.
we'll zoom in here.
And what do you see right at the very
center of this symbol?
Symbolical array.
What do you,
what is that?
I think it's a barn.
It's not a bar of the ark,
the ark,
it's,
you know,
it's probably a noah's ark of noah's
ark.
So that's the.
So that's supposed to be the ocean
around it and it's floating in the
waters of the great flood.
And,
and if you look closely,
I know it's hard to tell,
but growing out of here,
that's a chicken.
What's an acacia?
The acacia has impatient bush,
a masonic symbol for rebirth
regeneration,
rejuvenation.
So the idea here is that iN that arch is
preserved all of the seeds,
the bIological diversity of the world
that is now being erased from the planet
by the waters of the flood,
the acacia.
Is it related to the acacia tree or the
case of bushes at the same sort of
thing?
Yeah.
You know,
that's the same bush that they believe
was responsible for moses having the
visions of god.
So what are they giving him the 10
commandments because the acacia bushes
rich and dimethyltryptamine.
Ah,
the flaming bush,
the being symbolic of somehow or another
extracting the dmt from that,
smoking it or lighting it on fire.
And that being the transmission method
for the dimethyltryptamine,
which of course is one of the most
profound psychedelic experiences and
gives people this feeling of being in
contact with the divine.
Now,
do you think it's any coincidence that
the freemasons have venerated the acacia
for hundreds of years?
It makes a lot of sense.
Makes a lot of sense,
doesn't it?
Yeah.
Well,
there's modern day scholars who are
looking at the story of moses and
connecting it to some sort of a
psychedelic trip.
Yeah.
Here is,
which is another thing that's slowly
being exonerated today.
Those ideas are being vindicated today.
Yeah,
way that before,
you know,
you would say just a few decades ago
that somehow or another moses was on
drugs and I'm like,
get the fuck out of here.
Yeah.
I think people would just.
And any real,
legitimate sort of stories being
connected to psychedelic drugs,
people would think of as being
preposterous and now and now worn more
accepted every day simply because the
evidence has accumulated overwhelming
the elephant there.
There's no question that in the llc and
mysteries,
they were imbibing some type of a
consciousness altering substance.
I think that there's no question during
the mithraic mysteries also.
They were,
they don't know what that was though,
right?
Not exactly.
Unless you,
you know,
I think,
um,
who was it?
Maybe Albert Hoffman and a couple
others,
they,
they wrote a book in the seventies on
the loc and mysteries where they were
talking about that.
And I read it so long ago,
I've kind of forgotten what their,
what their final conclusion was,
but it was definitely that they were
doing some type of a psychedelic potion
will even soma.
When you go back to the ancient hindus,
the soma being some sort of a mystery
concoction,
they don't know what it was,
but most likely had some sort of
psychedelic properties to.
I don't know what it was.
They don't know exactly what.
It was amazing when you consider the
fact that this stuff was so profound,
so important to them,
and now we don't even know what was in
it and most likely some concoction with
probably included psychedelic mushrooms.
Yeah.
Well I'm convinced that one of the,
one of the great boons to humankind is
psychedelics.
And it was a profound mistake to
criminalize it when we should have
venerated as ancient cultures did and
provided a context in which people could
do it with wisdom,
you know,
and propriety rather than driving it
underground,
you know,
and turning it into a criminal
enterprise that has been,
I think enormously had enormously
destructive consequences for our society
by,
by criminalizing this for the last half
century.
Yeah,
most certainly.
And you can see the difference in the
art of the 19 sixties,
especially when it comes to music,
the difference between the sixties and
the seventies,
that shallow nature of a lot of the
music that came out of the seven days in
the disco and all that stuff.
And then look at what was going on in
the sixties with hendrix and jim
morrison,
most likely psychedelic related.
Oh,
of course it was.
Yeah,
of course.
Led zeppelin,
the beatles.
The profound change in the music of the
beatles.
once they discovered lsd,
it inspired an enormous burst of
creativity.
It's really interesting.
Then what we're seeing now is huge
benefits in psychedelic therapy for
people with posttraumatic stress
disorder,
ice.
And it's out of war that we're finding
these therapies for people that went to
war and these therapies,
the best ones are psychedelics,
which is really amazing.
Well,
you know,
in my own case,
I basically went from being a juvenile
delinquent to the quest for god in one
weekend after my first basically.
So wow It was that,
that quick.
A lot of people have at the same story.
I mean,
terence mckenna spoke of his,
uh,
one of his trips to the jungle,
being that he was this sort of
narrative,
well,
just couldn't get it together.
and then he came out of it,
the psychedelic shaman.
I had this intense desire to spread the
word.
yeah.
Yeah.
Yep.
So,
yeah,
and I think we're definitely moving in
the right direction.
I just,
it's of course,
you know,
for me,
I'm impatient.
I want to see you move a lot faster.
I want to see us just end this
ridiculous drug war,
you know?
And,
and yeah,
of course there's going to be a downside
to it.
There's downsides to everything,
you know.
and,
but the upside is so substantial.
Upside is so substantial.
And the downside of it is minuscule
compared to the downside of the drug war
itself.
Not only that,
how about the drugs that we already have
that are legal to the drugs that are
sanctioned or the worst one?
Worst ones.
yeah.
Just we're not going to have a drug free
society.
I've had Dr.
Carl Hart on the podcast who's an expert
in this and is written some pretty
amazing stuff on it and one of the
things he said is not only do we not
want a drug free culture,
we've never had one.
No one has ever had an idea of a drug
free culture.
They've never existed.
Once people figured out a way to perturb
their normal states of conscious and the
benefits of that,
whether it's alcohol or psychedelics or
whatever it's been.
Even yoga and meditation,
you're essentially,
you're,
you're stimulating indogenous drugs.
Yes.
And,
and,
and see,
here's the thing.
Somebody brought this up.
I don't remember who.
It might've been somebody like richard
or something back
in the day saying,
you know,
you can go.
You can embark on a quest for spiritual
enlightenment in and mystical at one
moment,
right through through this arduous
program of yoga and meditation and in,
in all of that,
and it'll take you years,
but who is going to embark upon such a
program?
Not really knowing that the end of it is
this ecstatic,
mystical union with the god had.
Right?
Well,
they said it basically.
Nature's provided shortcuts so that you
know,
we could actually see what the goal of
it was and know that,
yeah,
at the end of this process that might
take you 10 years or five years or
whatever,
depending on your dedication.
There is this all this experience of
your consciousness expanding into these
ecstatic states agents of evolution as
it were,
and that's the thing that people,
I think universally feel from
psychedelic experiences,
is that it allows you to get over a lot
of these sort of built in instincts that
we have from our thousands of years of
evolution and the the time that we were
essentially living like wild animals.
those,
those genes are still in our system and
we have all these ideas of paranoia.
And fear and ego and jealousy and all
these different things that allowed us
to be ultra competitive,
which allowed us to innovate at a faster
rate,
which allowed us to get to where we are
in 2015.
But those things are kind of hampering
us because we were outgrowing the monkey
body.
It's like,
you know,
if we're going to travel to um,
we wanted to travel to europe,
right?
You can't drive there in a car,
you can go drive from here to the east
coast.
But once you get to the coastline,
you have to get out of the car and get
into a different vehicle,
right?
Because if you keep driving in the same
car,
you're going to go into the ocean and
you're going to drown.
Right?
We're kind of liked that in the sense
that,
you know,
see,
I think that war was perhaps inevitable.
You know this because it's embedded in
our consciousness.
You see,
I just showed you hear evidence that the
human population crashed coming out of
the younger dryas.
Well,
what's ironic is that after the,
after the ice age was over for about
three or 4,000
years from 6,000
to about 9,000,
9,500
years ago,
what we had was a period known as the
climatic optimum by the scientists who
have looked at it in which some of the
estimates are that Global average
climate might've been two to four
degrees warmer than now.
What that meant was that you had a much
longer growing season and anybody who
doubts is please do your own research or
I can post all kinds of stuff online
that anybody who's not immediately,
you know,
can't handle this.
This can kind of information.
Anybody who's open minded can actually
go and do their homework and see that
the climate climatic is well
documented and for about three to 4,000
years basically we were living in an
almost quasi parodies iol state.
Almost a garden of eden.
Like it was almost like after their
traumatic birth of this modern age.
The holocene that we're in.
It's like nature just sort of was this
nurturing environment.
It was during this period that humans
were worshiping.
The earth in the form of this corpulent
pregnant goddess,
right?
It's been called the goddess
civilization by maria gimbutas,
who was the archaeologist who did all of
this work.
And what was interesting,
if you look into her work,
is that during this period of the,
of the early neolithic in the
archaeological terminology,
there is no evidence of any warfare.
There's no evidence that people are
looking at,
at the,
the,
the carvings that people did,
that the artwork that people did,
looking at the communities,
there were not stockades like there were
later.
There was no evidence in the,
in the archaeological record of
weaponization.
And it makes sense because in the
aftermath of this extreme event that
ended the ice age,
which you had was huge areas of the
planet that were depopulated nature
quickly begins to reclaim.
And what you now have is you have this
sort of,
this benign warmth.
We're growing seasons are months longer
than now,
you know,
farming 14,
1500 feet higher in the mountains than
is now possible.
Um,
you know,
uh,
long,
longer growing seasons and rapid
expansion of population during this era.
This would have been the era,
you know,
think about what would the biblical
injunction that you always gave to adam
and eve,
what did he say?
Be fruitful and multiply,
replenish the earth,
and subdue it.
Be fruitful and multiply.
Well.
If you've got a species hovering on the
brink of extinction,
what's the most important thing that
that species can do?
Lots of sex,
lots of reproduction,
right?
In the context of those times,
it would've been very important for
people to have lots of sex too quickly,
reestablish the viability of the human
species because we were literally at now
appears hovering on the brink of
extinction.
As were so many of the other large
mammals of the planet,
right and nature gave us this interval,
this window,
three or 4,000
years of extremely mild climate,
right.
During this time,
human population rapidly expanded and
moved into these vacated habitats.
Around 6,000
years ago,
the climate shifted.
What started was has been called by the
paleoclimatologists,
the neo glaciation because the planet
cooled a couple of degrees.
What happened?
Agricultural habitats contracted.
The growing the,
the,
the elevation of viable agriculture came
down.
Okay,
now if you've got settled human
communities that have become well
established and living,
uh,
in the context of that environment and
now suddenly that environment changes,
right?
Exactly.
Coincident with those environmental
changes around 6,000
years ago is when we see the first
appearance of human conflict because now
with this changing climate,
you've got this disruption is major
disruption in human communities that
have been well established and
proliferating for three or 4,000
years.
Think about,
you know,
if you're living in a community in your
farming at 10,000
feet above sea level,
a smaller example,
a micro example would be the freezing
out of the,
of the greenland colonists with the
onset of the little ice age,
right?
For 500 years they were able to farm on
the west coast of greenland and then the
little ice age came on and they were
frozen out and they tried to hang on as
long as they could,
but it kept getting harder and harder to
grow crops.
And then the climate declined further
and the cis began to move south.
And the one who waited too long lost
their opportunity.
Because once the cia said moved south at
cutoff the lanes so that they could
actually evacuate greenland colonies
completely went extinct.
Iceland itself was almost completely
depopulated during this.
If we take that scenario,
expand it,
and go back 6,000
years ago,
we essentially see a very similar
parallel phenomena going on,
and so when you figure for during it a
civilization age of the goddess,
this,
this time that people were worshiping
the earth in the form of this corpulent
pregnant goddess,
this benign,
motherly,
nurturing goddess,
there was no reason for conflict because
human populations were small,
they were isolated.
Resource base was enormous,
and then with the climate change,
what happened suddenly,
now human communities and populations
are disrupted.
Migrations began happening.
One group conflicts with another group,
and now we see the implements and the
evidence of warfare.
If we go back to 10,000,
12,000
years ago,
clearly whatever happened then must have
been profoundly traumatic to the
survivors.
Think about this.
If you were the survivor of an event
that basically erased modern
civilization and you were living in a
small,
isolated banda survivors with no way to
communicate with the rest of the world
and no knowledge of whether there was
even other survivors anywhere on the
earth,
it could profoundly affect your,
your,
your consciousness,
and that could be so profound that it's
the imprint of those events could be so
profound that it could be passed on for
generations and and be lodged in our
subconscious.
This idea of human conflict necessary
for human survival into traumas that had
been visited upon our species by nature
itself.
So I think that once we come to terms
with the possibly origins of only until
we come to terms with the origin of
human conflict,
are we going to be able to purge it once
and for all and and realize that that
the modern analog for that scenario was
that coming out of that catastrophe.
Abundant resources,
abundance,
habitat,
abundant space,
no conflict for territory or resources
because the human population was
limited.
What I suggest is that if people want to
understand the future of the human
species,
go out on a crystal clear night and look
at sky.
There is the future.
There's our potential future because the
scenario is that had been around since
the 1970 [inaudible] show that
everything that we're extracting now
from the earth,
the minerals,
the precious metals,
the hydrocarbons,
it's all out there in infinite abundance
and it's basically just outside of our
doorstep and we are as close now to
being able to harvest the resources of
the cosmic environment as we were from
setting foot on the moon in 1960.
Do you think we've been visited before
by something from other planets?
I think perhaps long,
long ago maybe,
but there's another scenario there that
has been overlooked In all of the
discussions about ufo is an aliens and
at some point we'll talk about that some
point.
Yeah.
You tease.
Well,
you know,
it's the kind of thing where you kind of
need to lay out the case in,
in,
in what I like to do is basically
present the evidence and see if whoever
then draws the same conclusions from
that evidence that I have.
So.
Okay.
Let me,
let me put it to you this way in what we
were talking about at the very beginning
of this interview and in talking about
7,000
generations of people and and the fact
that in four or five generations we went
from horseback to rocket ships.
How many times in the last 7,000
years do you suppose that we could have
done that?
To me,
it's not implausible that we could have
achieved flight,
even interest in interplanetary flight
more than once.
Just as we have.
I guess.
Think about it,
we have,
we have achieved interplanetary flight
even though only manned expeditions to,
to near space,
but we're sending our satellites out
beyond the solar system.
All of this has come about in my
lifetime,
right?
Totally.
In my life.
Tall since the 1958.
My grandfather,
when he was a kid,
you know it was horses and a big point
is that if we died off now,
if there's some sort of mass extinction
event,
there'd be very
little evidence of this space travel,
thousands of.
There'll be no evidence.
All the aluminum,
all the stuff that the rockets out of it
would all be gone,
right?
The earth would aBsorb it.
Now,
let's just consider as a wild,
outrageous working hypothesis that
humans have been able to offload from
the planet prior to that prior to the
modern space age.
So at one point in time we went to mars,
there's probably somewhere a little
closer than that.
It would've made sense like the moon,
like the moon,
like we've been able to establish a base
on the moon.
Yeah.
Now this isn't.
Like I said,
great.
This is an outrageous heretic.
I'm what else?
You've done drugs,
man.
This is over.
It's time to lock me away.
Gag me,
muslim me.
In life,
we consider the fact that our
civilization,
you know,
if all your theories are true,
which they most certainly appear to be,
our civilization has been rebooted as of
12,000
years ago.
Modern civilization emerges somewhere
around 70,000
years ago and four point 6 billion years
of life on earth,
or excuse me,
of the life of the earth,
the earth,
existing,
and then life on earth being,
you know,
in our form what few hundred thousand
years,
right?
In 100,000
years is all,
oh,
time.
That's 10,
10 events since the big impact 10 times.
But remember the greenland ice core
graft and they showed you,
I mean,
what you're seeing there is a dozen or
more enormous events in the last
quarter,
million years into time.
Probably the human getting the oldest
human skeleton,
modern modern humans.
Skeleton is now dated to about 180,000
years.
How much earlier than that?
Where we,
I don't know,
but conservatively we can say 180,000
years at greenland ice core grafted,
I showed you,
it goes back 250,000.
So the rig veda stories of the amanas
and the flying crafts and all that could
actually have been based on real live
objects,
real live spaceships that someone read
the sumerian stories.
What did they say in the wake of the
flood?
It was so disastrous that what did the
gods do?
They fled the earth and went to space.
It says right there in the myth itself,
since they left,
they went,
when they left the earth and went to the
heavens because what was going on on
your earth was so traumatic.
It even freaked them out.
Read the story,
the gods,
hanky and ian and nunan,
nerc,
don and the rest of.
What did you think of zechariah
situation and is fantastical
translations of the sumerian texts
dubious about some of his most are
right?
most people who are experts in the
sumerian cuneiform.
Yeah.
I think that he was kind of cuckoo.
Cuckoo,
cuckoo.
Well,
but what's fascinating is there's so
much that they absolutely understood
that's really confusing.
Like they understood they had an ad,
an accurate depiction of our solar
system,
which included pluto,
which included all the planets and all
the orbit in,
in,
in the correct,
you know,
relatively correct sizes on these clay
tablets that they made nine thousand
seven thousand dollars,
who knows how many thousand years ago,
you know?
Yeah.
I guess I'm,
I read some kitcheN and stuff years and
years ago and at the time took it with a
grain of salt and subsequent to that,
you know,
after I've seen some of the critiques of
him,
you know,
I'm kind of in that category myself.
I'm thinking because he's,
you know,
his,
some of his translations are,
are dubious.
He made some leaps.
Sure.
But what they did discover what they
have just,
it's so fascinating to me when you look
at like the caduceus,
which very clearly resembles the double
helix of dna and how it's closely
associated with some of these images of
larger beings holding little smaller
people with tails.
Like what the fuck is that?
Like this idea of genetic engineering,
of taking lower primates and introducing
human or alien dna into these lower
primates to create modern humans.
I don't know what to think about that.
It sounds ridiculous,
but if we found a planet like let's say
we exist in this state right now,
and uh,
we,
uh,
we evolve without getting hit in the
head by a big rock from space for
another thousand years or another 10,000
years.
Let's get really fucking crazy.
Just imagine how far we could come if we
don't blow ourselves up.
We don't.
Yellowstone doesn't explode.
We live another 10,000
years and we jet off into the cosmos and
find some planet with a bunch of dumb
monkeys on it.
You don't think we would splice our dna
into those dumb monkeys just to say,
listen,
I think you guys could do better.
You could be like us.
We're going to give you a little bump.
We know what's coming.
If you guys keep going along this way,
you could get to where we are in the
million plus years.
Weakened a little injection maybe.
How about a scenario like this?
Okay,
well from our superior perspective,
we know that you guys down here are
living on a vulnerable planet that's
going to be habits to ask kicked every
so often,
so we're going to do something to
accelerate your evolution a bit so that
perhaps you can become a little bit more
intelligent and figure this out.
We're going to leave some clues behind
for you and then we're going to leave it
in your hands to basically redeem to
redeem the planet.
It's amazing how often people just like
completely dismissed any ideas like
that,
but yet we clearly are.
We're very advanced in compared to life
on earth,
but clearly we're advancing into the
solar system at the very least with
robots.
You know,
we,
we haven't really been doing man space
trips
anymore,
but we're sending a lot of fucking
robots.
Yeah,
we're sending satellites,
we're sending all these things to go
around other planets and take images.
Were sending robots that land on mars to
rove around and take photos and soil
samples and send information back
through the sky to earth.
I mean,
that's pretty.
It is fantastic stuff.
Well,
imagine if you tried to describe to this
this to somebody 100 years ago,
they'd go get outta here.
This is outrageous.
I don't even want to hear such
ridiculous,
but like you just said,
considering the pace of change over the
last century,
you know,
given us a century ago,
there was no airline industry,
but of course the thing was if you know,
if you had the government bureaucracies
like you like you have now back then
orville and wilbur would have never been
able to test their flights because some
government bureaucrat would have been
out there saying you don't have the
proper permits to do this.
And right now that's,
You know,
one of the big obstacles is that we've
gotten.
We've got these top heavy political
systems that are really,
I think really encumbering the creative
process,
the evolutionary process.
That's why I'm such a big supporter of,
of basically freedom in getting back to
the idea of,
of individual liberty.
Because think the upside of people being
free.
Yeah,
of course there's a cost to freedom and
there's going to be a downside to it.
But the upside,
I think,
again,
is so much greater than the downside
that led to what the internet is showing
the internet is.
It represents freedom.
The free,
the ability to freely distribute
information.
This show itself would have never
existed.
This podcast could not have existed
without something like the internet.
No one would have ever given me a show.
no one would ever like said,
yeah,
go talk to this guy from Georgia for
three hours about asteroid impacts.
People will like it,
you know,
get outta here.
Get the fuck out of here.
Actually,
I'm from Minnesota.
Well,
I mean you live there,
you know.
but it's just the whole idea is that
freedom allows people to innovate at a
much quicker pace.
It allows negative things too.
But so does life itself.
there's,
there's more of a chance of negative
things.
If things are controlled,
if things are locked down and innovation
goes,
where does it goes right out in my own
personal sphere,
like 20 years,
like I'm building a project right now in
atlanta.
Took me six months and nine trips down
to city hall to get permission from the
bureaucrats to do a small project,
which 20 years ago I could have gotten
permission in an hour to 20 years before
that I didn't even would have been,
would not have even needed permission
from anybody,
you know,
oh,
you've got your own house,
you want to do this,
your neighbors don't care.
We'll do it.
See,
so this is what my experience there.
Multiply that by millions across the
board,
you know,
it's like,
it's going to get to the point where,
you know,
can we,
do
we dare breathe out without a permit
because we're exhaling carbon dioxide,
you know?
Right.
So,
um,
yeah,
I just,
I,
I think that a couple of things need to
happen.
One,
we need to really get back to the idea
and America,
that's the great dream and vision of
America was that this was supposed to be
the home of freedom on planet earth.
your bureaucracy is pretty disgusting,
but it's also,
I feel like sometimes we need some
resistance in order to facilitate
action.
Some resistance.
Yeah.
And some resistance.
Sometimes gives us this real desire to
overcome that resistance,
which makes innovation.
Yeah,
you know,
and that might be one of the things that
we're experiencing with this new culture
that's emerging from the internet.
It's kind of emerging in response to the
resistance that we received from mean
going back to psychedelics from the
sixties and seventies,
seventies into the eighties and the
nineties.
The internet emerges and the internet is
causing this big pushback on all of the
archaic ideas of being promoted during
those dark decades.
Yeah,
and I totally agree with you.
I mean without some resist.
I mean,
after all,
I mean if there's no resistance,
you know,
we.
We're going to basically turn it into
slugs.
We turned the couch,
potatoes,
we turned the couch with the lazy.
We're lazy.
Yeah.
It's very rare that human beings by
default are ambitious.
It's like in response to something like
one of the worst things you could do to
a kid is give the kid everything they
want and not have them work.
Though they'd never develop any
instincts to work towards things.
They never develop any,
any instincts to recognize that there's
a benefit to struggling and being
uncomfortable and that the rewards when,
when you have a hard day's work and a
job completed,
that you feel satisfied,
but then the beer tastes so much better,
so much better.
The jewish cabela's have a term for
that,
which I can't remember,
but it translates as the bread of shame
and it's like the bread of shame is the
bread you get that you didn't really
have to work for.
You didn't have to struggle,
you didn't have to put forward any
effort.
It's just given to you,
you know,
and,
it's like one of the,
the stories that kind of goes along with
presenting that as,
you know,
the,
the man who builds up this great
business empire,
you know,
and then you know,
he's getting ready to retire and he
wants to pass it onto his son and he
says,
you know,
come in and I'm going to make you ceo of
my business empire in the hole.
You're going to be Able to run the whole
thing.
And the son says,
no,
thanks.
I don't want,
and he goes,
well,
what do you mean?
He says,
well,
let me start at the bottom and work my
way up and earn that position and it's
going to mean a whole lot more to me and
I'm going to be a hell of a lot more
effective in that position and if it's
just dumped in my lap.
It's just so rare that anybody has that
mentality though most people would take
the easy road every single time.
Well,
and that is to the consternation,
I think of our who didn't look at it
that way.
You know the people that came across the
ocean,
it great hardship,
didn't look at it that way and I think
that they would be pretty much rolling
in their graves if they could see.
You know what's basically,
oh well we'll let you.
We'll just let the government take care
of us.
I don't have to get a job because the
government's going to take care of us,
but they would also look at our
computers and go,
holy shit,
you guys have figured some thIngs out.
God.
Wait a minute,
hold on.
You asked a question to your phone and
it gives you the answer.
I mean,
they never even thought about that on
star trek and and see what that does is
it shows there's 30 these parallel
trends that are,
that are happening,
you know,
so yeah,
I'm,
that's why I tend to be more optimistic.
I'm not a pessimist.
I,
I have great hopes for her future.
I do too.
And people give me a hard time for it.
Sometimes you think I'm unrealistic or
the hippie side of me.
Hippie ideology as well.
The sacred geometry,
sacred geometry name.
Like why did you choose that as the name
for your website?
Well,
because at the time I was looking at
there was so much interest and because I
saw it as a venue for putting
information out there about that and
showing some of the amazing correlations
and linkages between the subject of
geometry and so many of these other
things.
like I said,
you know,
the mayan temples,
egyptian structures in helping,
using that as a key to decipher or
decode these messages that have been
have been embodied in architecture.
It's the key.
It's a master,
it's one of the master keys to decoding
the archaic,
true wisdom tradition.
There's no question and geometry
pervades everything.
I mean geometry pervades,
you know,
we can actually,
I can show you now studies that have
shown that the exact architecture of the
solar system,
if you change it even a little Bit,
none of this could happen,
you know,
because as it is now,
you have this great reservoir of
comments outside the orbit of neptune
called the kuyper disk right at the
inside of that,
an inner perimeter of that disk of
comets,
commentary in stable condition.
In other words,
it doesn't take much to perturb them
from that position,
but at the same tIme there isn't much
there to perturb them,
so they generally are just slowly
orbiting the sun.
Well,
what happens is conjunctions of the
outer planets,
uranus and neptune primarily the
combined gravitational forces exerted on
the inner part of the kuyper disk or
enough to dislodge comments and send
them either either the gravity effect.
Think of this,
if you've got a gravity effect,
polling on something from behind and
it's moving this way,
it's going to act as a breaking
mechanism.
If it's a head in drawing on it,
it's going to act as an accelerating
mechanism,
so if you accelerate one of these
objects,
it moves out further from the sun.
If you decelerate it,
it moves in closer to the sun.
What happens is is that the conjunction
of the outer planets can move these
comments inside the the become within
the sphere of influence of the planets
and it just so happens in an
astrophysicist have worked out the
mathematics of it,
that the masses and the spacing of the
four great outer planets,
jupiter,
saturn,
uranus,
and neptune are exactly what they need
to be to transport comments from the
kuyper disk to the inner solar system,
and if you change that even a little
bit,
you would lose this.
They've referred to it as the the bucket
mechanism or the like a bucket handoff.
Each planet.
We'll hand off the comet to the next
one,
and then when it gets to jupiter,
the big one,
like you said earlier,
jupiter is either going to accelerate it
and throw it back out or it's going to
decelerate it and send it in towards the
sun.
Work becomes an earth crosser where it
begins to desegregate and into process,
fertilize the earth with its
constituents,
which we now know are all kinds of
interesting and exotic materials,
so if it turns out,
and it almost certainly will in terms of
the panspermia idea that that life was
originated on earth by comments that you
had to have an environment that was
conducive.
You had to have this matrix of
environmental conditions that if were
altered slightly,
would not allow the proliferation of
higher life.
You now have the introduction of
cometary material into that.
Well,
if the architecture of the outer solar
system was not exactly lined up into
geometry that it is,
then you would never have that delivery
of the organics and the volatiles from
the comet.
It's Backed.
It's likely that the oceans,
that the hydrosphere originated from
space without the oceans,
where would life on earth be?
You see now here's where it gets
interesting.
The architecture of the solar system is
what's condensed and embodied within the
sacred architecture of old,
so they've taken that those proportion,
however that got there,
whether they knew it directly or on some
subconscious level and incorporated that
into the designs and the proportions of
the ancient sacred structures.
It's there.
Basically the model of the holy city,
the new jerusalem is described in the
book of revelations is basically a model
of the solar system architecture,
so it abides by bodes law.
Is that what it is?
Yes.
I think it's bid day.
I think that's how you say it,
but god,
he would just be,
oh,
d,
e,
b o d o.
It's bowed day and I've only seen it
written and the lobbying that the size
and mass of a planet allows you to
extrapolate and find out how big and far
away the next planet would be,
and so yeah,
it shows up that one of the intervals
within that sequences,
for example,
where the asteroid belt is [inaudible],
there's no planet there there,
but there's an asteroid,
right,
and that's of coincides with the ancient
sumerian myth of the creation of earth
being an impact that there was an also
earth and earth to.
They know that earth was at one point in
time different and it was impacted and
that's also what created the moon,
right?
Yeah.
Well that's,
that's the theory about the moon,
but the moon,
the moon is really something we could
talk about for the next hour and we can
save that for a future broadcast,
but the moon is really one of the grand
symbols of the great mysteries with a
capital lamp.
No question.
And it's right there every night.
I mean,
right now,
I think we're one day away from the full
moon right now as we're sitting here,
and I would highly recommend that
anybody listening to this go out and
begin contemplating the moon unless
you're afraid of werewolf's unless
you're afraid of where,
unless you're afraid of becoming
transformed into a werewolf.
Um,
yeah.
So the,
the.
How is jerusalem designed representation
as a representation of the solar system?
Uh,
well,
the,
the hypothetical jerusalem,
the new jerusalem,
well describes this layout.
It gets complex.
And again,
when I show this to people,
I usually rely on a lot of graphs and
images and reproductions,
geometric diagrams and so on.
But basically it's describing tHe city
lies four square,
the length,
the height and the breadth of it or
equal 12,000
furlongs.
And there's a walgreens and high 144
cubits according to the measure of a man
that is of the angel.
And then it goes on to describe other
things,
but it's when you begin to begin to do
the analysis of these numbers,
you discover it.
It opens up this whole world of,
of numerical symbolism.
the 12,000
furlongs you know,
how,
how much,
uh,
furlong is no a long.
It's one eighth of a mile.
It still exists.
It's in very ancient unit of
measurement.
Still exists.
It's used in horse racing.
That's the one place that I know of.
It's still exists.
One eighth of a mile at 660 feet right
now.
If you were to take the earth,
the earth,
you know,
it's an oblique spheroid.
It spins on its axis,
so it bulges towards the equator,
shrinks towards the polar axis.
So the difference is about 7,900
miles at the polar axis,
about 7,926
miles at the equatorial access.
But if you were to take a perfect sphere
with the same area,
surface area is the earth actually has
that sphere would be 7,920
miles in diameter.
Now that number 797920th.
A very interesting number because for
one thing,
if we look at a furlong furlong is 660
feet.
So I'm putting 660.
Why don't you take that calculated?
Okay?
Okay.
Now that's a furlong 660 feet.
Convert that to inches by going times 12
times times 12,
one slash two.
Okay,
and equals equals seven.
Nine,
two zero.
There it is.
Diameter of the earth and miles that I
just said,
right,
right.
The,
the,
the perfect sphere that would have the
same surface area and the same volume is
the earth is 7,920
miles.
That's and that's actually the the
diameter of the earth.
If you took a line from the tropic of
cancer,
23 and a half degrees north through the
earth to the tropic of capricorn,
you would discover that that diameter is
about 7,920
miles.
That's the number which I'm theorizing
and,
and I'm thinking with a lot of evidence
to back up that ancient peoples use to
symbolize the earth.
Seven thousand 920.
But what you've just seen here is that
this ancient unit of measurement called
the furlong,
which is 660 feet is to the inch exactly
as the earth is to the mile.
Now,
what was the origin of the mile?
WHere did this myra,
we see we brought it up earlier,
length of the mile.
Five thousand 280 feet,
right?
What's the.
Or think about the latin word mill.
What does that mean?
A thousand,
right?
Like a million is a thousand.
Thousands of a millimeter is 1000th of a
meter,
right?
Because they're prefixing mil.
The middle,
the latin prefix,
that means a thousand,
right?
So that's where the actual word mild
comes from.
So a mile is a thousand what?
So thousand paces.
Human paces.
So if you were to go out and walk off a
thousand paces,
say counting every time your right foot
hit the ground,
you did add a thousand times,
you're going to have a mile more or less
depending on your size.
You know,
I'm six foot one,
so I'm going to have a slightly longer
pace than somebody who's five foot five.
Right?
But that's where the origin of the mild
comes from,
from 5,000
from a thousand paces.
And given that the,
that,
that standardized,
but it's very ancient.
Safe.
Now,
the outer circle of stonehenge,
the sarsens stone circle,
if you were to encompass it in a circle
that just tangent to the outer faces of
the stone,
the radius of that circle is,
has been,
has been measured,
and it's almost exactly 52 point eight
feet right,
or 100 of a mile.
Now,
if you take the diameter of stonehenge,
it's a double it,
which is 105 point six feet,
right?
50 times 100 point 105 point six.
There's your mile.
It suggests that the mile was being used
by those who built stonehenge 5,000
years ago,
but you see this number five,
point two eight is a universal
relationship.
It it.
For one thing,
it says
the average human pace related to the
foot,
which again,
remember protocols said man is the
measure of all things,
right?
Where comes the inch?
It's this.
Here's the x right here.
The origin of the inch.
The distance between your thumb.
Yeah,
or it's already width of your thumb.
It's this.
Well,
yeah,
so you can.
You can measure here and that's going to
be an inch or you can take this and
that's an inch as well.
So.
Okay,
so it's the tip of your thumb to the
first joint.
Yes.
As essentially an.
And it depends because obviously you're
trying to size,
right?
Right.
But the idea here is that the units of
ancient measurement derive from one of
two sources from the human yard stick or
the earth itself.
Okay,
so now if you take the average human
pace divided by the average human foot,
it's five point two eight,
multiply that by a thousand and you have
the mile of 5,000,
280 feet.
Right?
I'm suggesting that that unit of
measurement was actually incorporated
into the design of stonehenge.
Right now,
what we have just seen is that the
description of the new jerusalem in the
book of revelations describes it as
being 12,000
furlongs,
which again is an ancient british
unitive measurement,
but probably used way beyond britain.
And when we look at the ratio of the
furlong,
if we took out in the parking lot here
and laid out a furlong 660 feet,
and then marked off one inch on it,
that furlong to that inch would be
exactly the same as the diameter of the
earth to the mile.
Now in in the book of revelations,
what it says is that the new jerusalem
is 12,000
of these furlongs.
So if you take 660,
which I put in there times 12,000,
look at the number that comes up again,
there's a number again,
seven,
nine,
two zero,
zero,
zero.
But it's been raised by orders of
magnitude.
Now divide that by the number of feet in
a mile.
Put the divide button here,
divide by 5,280
divided by 5,280.
And there is what they're describing a
body that's 1500 miles in diameter,
right?
So what is that?
What is 1500 miles in diameter?
That's the mystery.
Now,
if you take that number,
and I'm going to go to the earth itself,
79 slash 20 and divided by the new
jerusalem,
divide by 1500.
There's the ratio.
We get the human pace to the human foot.
Whoa.
Coincidence,
or are we beginning to see that there's
an underlying pattern now?
Five to eight,
five to eight,
so
the ratio is there,
right?
I'm not making any of this up,
so you either dismiss it as coincidence
or you go,
okay,
there's an underlying pattern here and
it's got some meaning to it.
Now I think it's going to be beyond our
Ability today to really get into that,
but this is the kind of thing.
Would you be to peel back these layers?
You begin to discover that there are,
these ratio is built into this.
So it's some in a sense
it's fractal,
yes.
Wow.
And,
and the idea here,
just like protocol has said that,
that we humans were the measure of,
of all things.
And in all of these cosmic dimensions
are miniaturized and encoded in our very
anatomy,
randall carlson,
we have run out of time,
but you have blown minds on multiple
front.
Once again,
man,
we gotta do another one.
When's the next time you tell me a good?
Well,
give me a few months to recover from
this one.
Okay.
You tell me.
I'm going to bed for a week now.
Yeah,
I'm sure it was quite a burst of
information,
but thank you sir.
I really,
really appreciate it.
It's always a pleasure having you here.
What?
You're one of my favorite podcast
guests.
Without a doubt.
I enjoyed so much and I'm going to go
over this podcast with a fine tooth comb
and try to figure it out.
I want to say one more quick thing.
A lot of this information that I've been
talking about here is on our dvd that
you can get online,
a cosmic patterns and cycles of
catastrophe.
Where are you getting all of the images
and a lot of the background and the
stuff that we went into.
So if you go to the sacred geometry
international website,
you'll be able to find a link and find
out all about it.
What is the exact website sacred
geometry geometry international dotcom,
I guess.
So if you just put sacred geometry
international into search engine,
it'll be the first thing that comes up
in your google and your twitter handle
is sacred geometry int correct,
right?
Yeah.
Is it right?
Hold on a second,
I'll check it out real quick.
Sacred?
Yeah.
Sacred geo int.
Okay.
So sacred geo at sacred g o I n t.
Thank you.
My friend is a massive honor and a
privilege and a pleasure and I
appreciate this so much.
Thank you.
I appreciate you having me.
Joe.
Listen man.
Changed the world.
You're the world.
Believe me.
Your freaking the fuck out while you're
helping me.
Joe randall,
randall carlson,
lazy gentlemen.
He will be back in a few months.
We'll let him recover.
We'll send them some vitamin c,
send them some supplies.
We'll get them back out here.
Thank you brother.
I really appreciate it.
Wow.
Hmm.
Oh yeah.
Well if you don't drink much coffee,
that stuff will.